Guten Morgen Linus.
Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Zurück aus dem Urlaub bist du? Sind wir. Ja. Das ist gut.
Zurück aus dem Urlaub ist Lokbuchnetzpolitik und das hier ist die vierundsiebzigste Ausgabe, die wir jetzt nachlegen, hier frisch aus der Mieterebene,
Und äh weil man ja nach solchen Pausen auch immer so ein bisschen schüchtern und verlegen wird, haben wir uns dann auch gleich äh Verstärkung äh eingekauft. Stimmt's?
Ja und zwar ist bei uns Anna Roth.
Guten Morgen.
Warum haben wir äh Anne eingeladen?
War auf der oben.
Laufe um, aber vielleicht müssen wir, also ich weiß nicht, ob man Anne noch vorstellen muss. Man sollte sie nicht vorstellen müssen, aber wir machen's trotzdem. Äh oder du ja, ja.
Ich jetzt? Äh oder du, ja, ja.
Auch machen die das.
Möchtest du mich vorstellen.
Äh ich habe Angst, dass ich da irgendwas falsches sage. Also Anne, Anne ist eine der der profiliertesten Netz,
Netzaktivistinnen und Feministinnen, die ich kenne.
Und Link generell Linken und korrekten Aktivistinnen. Siehst du, ich muss.
Rosa an hier.
Und Anne ist äh glaube ich, also hätte man hätten wir sowieso schon viel früher einladen sollen, weil sie ein ähm,
ja doch in der Netzszene relativ prominentes Opfer von staatlicher Überwachung ist. Und entsprechend auch eine äh.
Oder wahr?
Also Opfer gewesen ist, ja? Wissen wir gar nicht, ne?
Ich sehe mich ja nicht gerne als Opfer.
Siehst du, ich.
Ziel äh staatlicher Überwachung.
Ja, das trifft schon manchmal viel besser.
Zielperson staatlicher über du warst Zielperson. Du warst jetzt.
Ich bin ich bin äh bloß der Kollateralschaden gewesen. Ich bin ja bloß die die Ehefrau, nee, bin ich ja gar nicht, also Freundin von von André, dem das alles galt.
Genau, ja, die Story von André Holben, die ist sicherlich jetzt auch äh weithin bekannt, äh, geworden, äh
wer das auch nicht kennt, äh die Kurzfassung ist, man kann auch durch das Schreiben falscher Worte heutzutage schon in die entsprechenden Filter geraten und dann in eine Überwachungsmaschine
hinein geraten aus der man dann auch so schnell wieder nicht
rauskommt, der erfahrt ihr dann äh für eine längere Zeit ausgesetzt. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, über welchen Zeitraum sich das insgesamt dann letztlich äh hin.
Also in den Akten stand, dass das zweitausendsechs angefangen hat und zweitausendzehn aufgehört hat.
Zweitausendzehn dann kurzzeitigen Höhepunkt mit einer U-Haft hatte, wenn ich mich recht entsinne.
Ich kann ja mal kurz ausholen, ganz kurz. Ähm also die U-Haft und die Festnahme war zweitausendsieben, da haben wir davon erfahren, die Ermittlung,
ein Jahr vorher angefangen, die komplett Überwachung äh hat sich dann so langsam ausgedehnt, ähm also immer so eine Überwachungsanordnung, die gehen immer für drei Monate,
Und äh bin den BKA-Akten, was stand dann zu lesen? Wir haben nichts gefunden und deswegen, ähm, weil die sich so wahnsinnig konspirativ benehmen, müssen wir die Überwachung jetzt ausdehnen auf Freunde, Kollegen und so weiter und so ging das dann immer weiter. Ähm genau und zweitausendsieben,
ist er festgenommen worden, ähm weil andere, mit denen er ähm angeblich zu tun gehabt haben soll,
festgenommen worden sind, angeblich, weil sie einen Brandanschlag begangen haben sollen, äh für den, die dann später auch verurteilt wurden und ähm,
ist drei Wochen in U-Haft gewesen, ist dann auf Kortion wieder freigelassen worden, zwei Monate später hat der BGH den Haftbefehl wieder aufgehoben, weil der schon gar nicht hätte,
ausgestellt werden dürfen und dann ist aber noch drei Jahre weiter ermittelt worden. Unter anderem ähm war das ein langes Gezerre zwischen
BKA, Bundesanwaltschaft und
weil sie bei uns äh PGP verschlüsselte Dateien festgenommen äh festgenommen, mitgenommen haben und äh die nicht aufgekriegt haben und immer die haben wollten und die haben sie aber nicht gekriegt und deswegen immer, ja dann, dann kommen wir hier nicht weiter und deswegen zog sich das noch drei Jahre.
So ein bisschen wie wie bei Brasilien, ne, so die die äh Konfusion.
Ja, das ist, wenn man sich mit sowas beschäftigt, das ist sozusagen Standard, ja, also diese Sorte ermittlungsverfahren, die ähm auf Bundesebene dann angesiedelt sind. Das ist im Grunde so eine Art ausgedehntes Fingerhakeln
hat viel mit Psychotherapeut zu tun würde ich sagen. Also wie viel hältst du dann aus an Druck und Stress und ähm,
im Grunde passierte dann. Also zwischendurch sind dann auch so Sachen passiert, wie dass sie, dass sie ähm als eigentlich äh
das Ganze schon so halbwegs gegessen war, plötzlich eine DNA-Probe entnommen werden sollte, wo du denkst, wenn jemandem vorgeworfen wird, Texte geschrieben zu haben für eine terristische Gruppe, was hilft da eine DNA Probe? Ähm das ähm macht halt mehr Stress, aber das hat dann auch
Jahre gedauert, bis sie die ausgewertet hatten. Ist also jetzt nicht so wie im Tatort, dass sie dann in einer halben Stunde schon wissen, wer es war, sondern das BKA braucht dafür, ich glaube, zehn Monate.
Die Texte, das war ja noch ein interessanter Punkt, also wenn ich mich recht entsinne, ging es doch darum, dass ähm die militante Gruppe,
in Bekennerschreiben, Worte verwendet hat, die das BK nicht kannte. Woraufhin das BKA gegoogelt hat, also jetzt höre ich, ich überschwitze das jetzt mal. Also sie haben Worte benutzt, die auch in den wissenschaftlichen Veröffentlichungen von André vorkommen.
In Veröffentlichung von Amri der veröffentlicht nicht nur wissenschaftliche Texte und ich würde sagen, das ist sozusagen mit auch Grund natürlich äh also ich,
oder andersrum angefangen. Ich glaube nicht, dass alle Leute, die mal Gentrifizierung schreiben, sofort überwacht werden. Wobei mittlerweile wieder schon, weil inzwischen zum Beispiel der polizeiliche Staatsschutz Berlin Veranstaltungen, die irgendwie mit Gentrifizierung zu tun haben für Überwachungsbedürftig halten, weil ja ähm hier
Keine Ahnung, so viel Trubel ist zu dem Thema. Das war aber vor vor ein paar Jahren nicht so, da kannte das niemand ähm und äh.
Wie gesagt, ging nicht nur um wissenschaftliche Texte, sondern auch um andere zum Beispiel im Telegraf, was äh was eine ostberliner ähm politische Zeitschrift ist, die schon vor der Wende entstanden ist, die es jetzt immer noch gibt, in der André auch früher öfter jetzt nur noch selten schreibt
über politische Themen aller Art sozusagen und ähm.
Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass das alle Leute betrifft sowas, sondern eher, dass natürlich bei so was rausgefischt werden Leute, die äh die besonders,
aktiv in irgendeinem Kontext sind. Ich denke, dass solche Verfahren natürlich ähm auch.
Also neben sozusagen der ganz normalen rechtsstaatlichen Begründung, da gab es äh da gab es Bran
Brandanschläge und wir suchen die Verursacher und rein zufällig haben wir die Texte von diesem Mann in unserer Datenbank und die vergleichen wir jetzt mal zufällig mit den Texten von der militanten Gruppe und zufällig stoßen wir darauf, dass da Worte wie Gentrifizierung oder Reproduktion oder marxistischen Indistisch drin vorkommen und deswegen müssen das ja die gleichen sein.
Ähm ähm die Frage, warum Andres Texte in der in der BKA Textdatenbank
wissen wir jetzt auch nicht so genau, also wer den Luxus ähm erfährt, ist bis heute nicht klar geworden. Aber Andre ist eben nicht nur Wissenschaftler, sondern auch äh äh seit zwanzig Jahren Aktivist im Bereich Mieten und und Mieter und äh,
Wir waren beide beim G acht Gipfel der zwei Monate vorher gewesen war und ähm das kannst du durch die Geschichte beobachten und das sozusagen kann mich, glaube ich,
momentan kann man das auch sehr schön in der Hackerszene beobachten, dass sozusagen immer so ein paar Exempel statuiert werden, ja. Das wird werden Leute rausgefischt, an denen wird einmal so richtig das komplette drakonische Ding durchgezogen und dann,
zucken alle anderen hinterher kräftig und dann kannst du ungefähr sagen zwei Drittel zucken dann nicht mehr, weil weil das einfach
auch einen sehr abschreckenden Effekt hat. Also das eine ist der Effekt, Abschreckung, kann man sagen, ähm ist Paranoia, ist nicht bewiesen, halte ich jetzt aber nicht für besonders ähm frei erfunden
und das andere ist natürlich, dass solche Ermittlungsverfahren eben Überwachungs äh Möglichkeiten.
Mit sich bringen und zwar nicht nur der Person oder der Familie oder der Kollegen, sondern im Grunde aller Kontaktpersonen und der Kontaktpersonen davon, das heißt, wenn du ein so ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen jemanden anstrengst, kannst du die gesamte Szene drumrum durchleuchten,
Das wird regelmäßig gemacht und ich denke, das wird auch mit eine Funktion davon gewesen sein und das hat dann eben.
Mehr oder weniger zufällig andere getroffen, weil der in verschiedenen politischen Szenen und und Wissenschaftler, Zirkeln und,
ähm weiß ich nicht, so was wie der Mieterverein Berlin ist ja kein linksradikale Angelegenheit ähm aktiv war und gleichzeitig aber auch hier im Prenzlauer Berg äh vor vielen Jahren schon ähm äh,
bei wir bleiben alle mit aktiv gewesen, ist sozusagen in der ersten Runde davon und so was ist natürlich dann sicherlich interessant, mal genauer hinzugucken
wer mit wem zu tun hat und ich denke, das ist eine Ursache von sowas.
Tja, da kann man auch schon mal schön äh ablesen, wie das dann in Zukunft mit voll äh überwachten und auf ähm bestimmte Stich,
Worte hin untersuchten Chatsysteme äh wie sich das dann so in Zukunft äh entfalten wird, weil das ist ja einfach so dieser Klassiker, ne. Und äh,
Konfusion, dir sagt es sicherlich was, ne, aus dem Film äh Brasilien, da gibt's ja diese wunderschöne Stelle, ich kann das immer nur wieder zitieren, weil das einfach,
passt einfach grade auf auf das Ding wieder so wunderbar, ja, also am Anfang hast du da so Schreibmaschinen, die die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Haftbefehle ausdrucken und so ein Bürokrat, der da so gelangweilt, daneben sitzt,
hat gerade nichts besseres zu tun als mit einer Zeitung so auf Insektenjagd zu gehen, stellt dann auch irgendwann die
Fliege an der Decke und haut so von unten mit der Zeitung diese Fliege Matsch, die sich danach dann aber äh löst im zerquetschten Zustand und natürlich in diese Schreibmaschine hineinfällt und anstatt äh
Harry Tuttle wird dann halt Harry Buttle festgenommen so ja und daraus.
Daraus folgt dann sozusagen diese gesamte Konfusion äh dieses Films, ja, bis es dann halt so in den Geheimdienst kreisen, dann immer nur noch von dieser
Konfusion die Rede ist und das ist dann auch schon wieder eine Verschwörung in sich und so weiter. Also es ist einfach alles total großartig.
Finde ich immer wieder ein tolles Beispiel für was später alles zukommt und es wäre auch so eine kleine vierundachtzig angehauchte Passiflage.
Jetzt auch schon fast wieder dreißig Jahre her, ist mir neulich äh aufgegangen. Ähm,
Dazu finde ich ganz passend, dass ähm natürlich nach im Nachhinein bei solchen Sachen, auch wenn da irgendwas vielleicht mal schief läuft im BKA. Äh alles wunderbar legitimiert werden kann. Also das fand ich,
wenn man so will, interessant an diesem Verfahren, was sich ja aus der Nähe beobachtet habe und auch solche Akten viel gelesen habe
dass dass die wirklich alles irgendwie begründen können und sich so zurechtrücken können, dass es notwendig ist, irgendwen zu überwachen oder irgendein Verfahren zu führen. Also auch da, wo genau nichts zu sehen ist, das als Grund dafür zu nehmen, dass da irgendwas sein muss,
Und das, um sozusagen nochmal auf die ursprüngliche Idee der Vorstellung meiner Person so kurz zurückzukommen, äh war für mich dann der Anlass, einen Blog dadrüber zu schreiben und äh sozusagen tagtäglich zu dokumentieren, was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn man so ein Ermittlungsverfahren mit total Überwachung
erlebt und und welche Absurditäten da drin vorkommen. Ähm das habe ich zweitausendsieben dann zwei Monate später angefangen.
Unter dem Namen Analyst. Mhm.
Genau, ähm so in den in den ersten Texten davon da, da steht viel über über diesen ganz absurden Kram drin.
Äh was die sich ausdenken, warum irgendwas verdächtig wäre, ähm also,
Weiß ich nicht. Also Fluchtgefahr zum Beispiel, also als andere aus der U-Haft entlassen werden sollte. Ähm wurde dann von der Bundesanwaltschaft sofort Widerspruch eingelegt mit der also Grund für Untersuchungshaft ist ja unter anderem Fluchtgefahr,
und äh Fluchtgefahr sei deswegen gegeben, weil er irgendwann mal an einem Telefonat mit seiner Mutter über einen möglichen Job in Holland gesagt hatte, als sie fragte, wie soll denn das dann gehen mit der Familie? Naja, dann muss ich vielleicht erstmal
alleine hin und die anderen ziehen dann nach, wenn das mit dem Job klappt und daraus wurde dann die Fluchtgefahr konstruiert und.
Man muss dazu sagen, zu diesem Zeitpunkt war Andre Holm, ich glaube, grade noch nicht so lange promovierter äh Wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter am äh Institut für Sozialwissenschaften der Humboldt Universität zu Berlin,
ähm und es war natürlich, also das ganze Ding war natürlich auch deshalb für die äh
also ich habe zu dem Zeitpunkt auch äh da an der HU studiert und habe auch am Sowie Institut äh Veranstaltungen besucht. Leider nie äh eine von Andre selber besuchen können, weil dann irgendwann eine andere Uni gewechselt ist, wenn ich das äh.
Aber er ist jetzt wieder da und jetzt gibt's die Gelegenheit wieder.
Gelegenheit, ich habe aber keinen Studentenausweis mehr.
Ist echt schade.
Ähm und das genau und ähm promoviert hatte er ja zu gentrifation, ne.
Ja, er hat promoviert zur zur Aufwertung im Prenzlauer Berg. Gentrifizierung und Verdrängung ähm und so.
Und dann äh landet er wegen diesem wegen so etwas in Urheft. Ja, das war das war eine sowas von skurrile Situation, aber ich erinnere mich da noch äh.
Also die, die Studierenden an der Umweltuni fand ich super. Ich habe also sozusagen in dem Moment, als er festgenommen war, natürlich auch viel mit anderen Sachen zu tun gehabt, aber diese vielen verschiedenen Soli-Aktionen, wo Leute
in der in der Bibliothek von der Humboldtuni-Flugblätter verteilt haben, ähm dass man jetzt vorsichtig sein muss, weil schon das Lesen für Neues Zeitung als gefährlich erachtet wird, was ein Grund war, der im Haftbefehl anging
war. Ähm das war ziemlich großartig, das hat uns auch viel geholfen.
Es war eine starke Bewegung. Okay, äh lange Geschichte, viel, viel drüber zu lesen, wurde in vielen äh Sendungen auch aufbereitet, ähm wer das, wer mit dem Fall nicht vertraut ist, dem kann man das sehr.
Gibt sogar einen Spielfilm.
Genau, es gibt einen Spielfilm, aber den mochtest du nicht so, ne, weil die.
Von Hans Weingartner.
Wird er so ein bisschen.
Ja genau, das wird sozusagen, der ist teilweise so ein bisschen dokumentarisch, der hat sich auch lange mit uns unterhalten und,
ganz viele Details, die stimmen eben genau so, aber es ist kein kein Dokumentarfilm, sondern ein Spielfilm und ausgerechnet meine Rolle ist halt vollständig falsch, also das ist halt so ein so ein, so ein ängstliches Motchen, die an der Seite des des
Kämpfers ähm irgendwann weinend zusammenbricht und da habe ich doch ein bisschen drunter gelitten, muss ich sagen.
Also dann, ja, stimmt, deine Rolle ist da nicht also deine Rolle ist da nicht.
Wir haben uns dann hinterher auch darüber gestritten und äh da die Argumentation war einer es gab zwei sehr lustige Erklärungen, die ich,
Premierenparty davon äh äh mir von Kameramann und Regisseur habe vorhalten lassen müssen. Das eine war, dass der Schauspieler, der Andre spielt selber schon so eine relativ weiche Figur ist und,
ähm weil der aber ja die Hauptfigur war, musste sozusagen die Frau an seiner Seite noch noch noch weicher sein.
Die Blödsinn nicht.
Ähm,
fand ich auch total überzeugend und und das andere war, dass ähm, oh Gott, nee, ich hab's jetzt vergessen, aber also auch irgend so ein so ein Quatsch halt, dass äh.
Was meinen die mit weich? Also äh.
Das musst du mich nicht fragen.
Da ist sie keiner Expertin drin.
Das ja, okay, lassen wir das.
Zwänge, die Zwänge von nun Drehbuch und äh Spielfilmentwicklung, das ist nun nochmal was ganz anderes.
Aber die Schauspielerin hat sich für mich eingesetzt, hat sie hat sie also mit der habe ich mich natürlich auch unterhalten, weil die wissen wollte sozusagen so ein bisschen,
im Vorfeld genau und die hat dann hinterher nochmal angerufen und äh gesagt, sie hat einiges abwenden können. Ursprünglich sollte sie in Spitzenunterwäsche durchs Schlafzimmer und das hat sie aber verweigert,
Ja. Ähm.
Sag doch nochmal ganz kurz nochmal den Filmtitel, weil ich hab da gerade.
Der Gefährder von Hans Weingartner, das ist ist ein Teil eines sogenannten Omnibusfilms, der heißt Deutschland null neun, ähm der äh sozusagen ähm
so ein so ein dreißig Jahre nach Deutschland im Herbst äh von von nochmal so rekapitulieren sollte, wo befinden wir uns eigentlich Zustand von von Deutschland? Das.
Keine volle Spielfilmlänge, ne? Das war ein kurzes.
Deutschland nur neun, es dauert zwei Stunden und besteht aus, ich glaube zehn Kurzfilmen, die je ungefähr eine Viertelstunde lang sind und der Gefährder ist einer davon, gibt's bei unter anderem YouTube auch zu gucken.
Hm
Super. Wir äh verlinken,
So, es gibt viel über dich zu erzählen. Wir haben noch nicht ganz äh alles durch, ähm aber das gehört jetzt noch zu einer Vorstellung dazu. Du bist auch noch äh engagiert in einem ähm tja, wie drücke ich's aus? Äh.
Nichtregierungsorganisation.
In einer Nichtregierungsorganisation, ja, also ich habe jetzt überlegt, ob Aktivistengruppe hier äh das richtige Wort ist. Auf jeden Fall heißt es Tactical, Technology, äh collective kannst du da nochmal kurz was,
sagen.
Eine NGO, eine ganz normale NGO, die mit Fördergeldern äh Dinge tut, ähm die die wir für gut erachten und ähm also konkret
kurz vorm gibt's seit etwa zehn Jahren, hat angefangen damit äh zu versuchen, Aktivisten weltweit äh durch die Nutzung von neuen damals neuen, ja so einigermaßen neuen Technologien
zu helfen, ihre gute Sache voranzubringen. Vor allen Dingen erstmal über die äh Verbreitung von Open Source äh,
Software, die sowohl sozusagen für für ähm das Verbreiten von eigenen Botschaften das Gute, verbreiten von eigenen Botschaften zuzuwandern ist dann relativ bald umgeschwenkt auch oder oder hat sich,
auf äh äh also Sicherheit, ähm wie wie können sich Aktivisten sicher im Netz bewegen,
inzwischen haben wir eben diese diese zwei Programme. Das eine, was eher proaktiv
mittlerweile viel mit Daten und Visualisierung zu tun hat und das andere, was versucht sowas wie Verschlüsselung ähm bei anderen unterzubringen, was ähm was,
durchaus eine Herausforderung ist, wie wir alle wissen, wir arbeiten nicht in Europa, deswegen sind wir in Berlin relativ unbekannt, obwohl wir hier im Büro haben und noch eins in in Bengalor, in Indien,
arbeiten eben hauptsächlich mit Aktivisten, mit Menschenrechtsorganisationen, mit unabhängigen Journalisten und versuchen die dazuzukriegen ihrer
in der Regel Windows Rechner äh in der Regel vollkommen ungeschützt in der Regel keine Zeit, sich irgendwie mit sowas zu beschäftigen, so ein bisschen gegen Eingriffe von außen zu schützen.
Hm. Was nicht äh so einfach ist, wie man auch zuletzt die Nachrichten wieder äh erneut entnehmen konnte.
Was uns in eine sozusagen oft schwierige Zwischenposition zwischen einerseits ähm versuchen wir natürlich äh bestimmte Sachen, die die tatsächlich
so sicher wie möglich sind und Open Source sind und überprüft sind, aber meistens ähm in der Usability große Menge haben. Ähm sozusagen zwischen der Community und andererseits Aktivisten, die für sowas überhaupt keine Zeit haben und vielleicht auch kein Geld haben und vielleicht auch gar keine eigenen Rechner haben oder irgendwie vor allen Dingen mit Mobilgeräten unterwegs sind irgendwo in in Ländern mit
äh sehr viel repressiverer politischer Situation
und aber auch da vor allen Dingen erstmal ihre politische Sache voranbringen wollen und äh zu überlegen, wie kann man denen überhaupt irgendwie weiterhelfen, das ist ähm
großer ähm ja eine große Lücke, die da klafft zwischen dem, was was nötig wäre und was erreichbar ist.
Ja, jetzt können wir auch gleich mal einen äh Bogen schlagen, weil ich denke auch teilweise äh im Auftrage von Tactical, Tech warst du auf der oben.
Darf ich noch ganz kurz vorher meine loswerden? Das ist ein ganz, ganz kurz
Ich habe was Falsches gesagt in der letzten Sendung. Und zwar ähm haben wir über VPN Dienste gesprochen,
Und ich sagte, äh also insbesondere über Apple haben wir gesprochen und ich sagte, dass ich ja wohl hoffe, dass bei Appletar alles mit einer, also viele IPs reinkommen und alles durch eine Exit IP kommt
um zu verschleiern, wer, wer und was ist. Ähm das ist nicht so. Bei Predator bekommen doch jeder tatsächlich seine eigene IP.
Und der Grund dafür ist ganz einfach, wenn man nämlich Torens machen möchte mit draußen
also mit auch nicht dann muss natürlich trotzdem jeder seinen eigenen seine eigene IP haben sonst klappt das mit den ganzen nicht. Und ja also bei bekommt man
doch tatsächlich eine eigene Exit-IP. Das heißt, als äh NSA-Anonymisierungsdienst ist iPreda,
Anti-NSA-Anonymisierungsdienstes nur mäßig geeignet. Das war das Erratung und,
frohe Kunde ohne großartige äh äh Begründung oder äh sonst was äh kann man doch wieder per PayPal bezahlen. Es gibt keine weitere Äußerung dazu.
So viel habe ich bei der Oma gelernt, weil bei der oben trifft man ja Leute. Womit wir wieder bei der hätte ich.
Genau, äh da trifft man dann auch an.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ähm oben, ja, ich habe jetzt schon äh in zwei Sendungen versucht, diese Veranstaltung irgendwie für mich so ein bisschen zu summieren. Was mir ein bisschen schwer gefallen ist, muss ich sagen. Ähm.
Weiß nicht, was war denn euer Eindruck so?
Noch kurz sagen, was hier oben war?
Das Hacker Camp in Holland. Es gibt ähm alle vier Jahre in Deutschland einen Hacker Camp,
und alle vier Jahre in Holland ein und das ist so wie.
Länger als Deutschland.
Wie genau, das gibt schon sehr viel länger und das ist äh aber in letzter Zeit ist das quasi so wie EM und WM, ne, also die Periode ist um zwei Jahre verschoben, sodass man alle zwei Jahre campen gehen kann, einmal in Deutschland, einmal in Holland und ähm das diesjährige,
Holländische Hackercamp hieß oben und fand in bei Alkmaar in der Nähe von Amsterdam auf einer auf einer Wiese statt.
In der Nähe von Amsterdam sagt natürlich in Holland nicht viel aus.
Ist ja alles in der Nähe von Amsterdam. Na man fährt da immerhin schon mal.
Gut, ja, das ist im Land nicht gerecht, wenn du nicht deren Maßstäbe an Distanzen äh annimmst, ja. Also in der Nähe von Amsterdam, ja.
Gut. Ja, da waren wir auf jeden Fall draußen.
Und dieses Jahr war das irgendwie ein großes, ein großes hin und her mit diesem Camp, weil ähm.
Es ging schon irgendwie im April diesen Jahres irgendwie los, dass es Streitereien über ähm die Aufstellung des Teams, die das Camp veranstaltet,
Dieses Teams, dass das Camp ausrichtet und
Sponsoren dieses Camps gab und zwar ähm ist der größere Teil des des Omen Orgateams beschäftigt bei einer äh oder ein großer Teil des um Orgateams beschäftigt bei einer Firma namens Fox IT.
Und ähm an
Machenschaften dieser Firma gibt es so einige Kritik. Unter anderem äh finden sich auch Broschüren über Produkte dieser Firma in den Wiki League Spikes. Da geht's dann um äh
irgendwelche Systeme und so. Also äh Lösungen für für sind offensichtlich auch Teil dessen, was Fox IT macht,
Ähm,
Ich muss sagen, dass ich mich da im Detail gar nicht mehr weiter mit auseinandergesetzt habe, aber schon im bevor dieses Camp überhaupt stattfand, gab es eine äh große Debatte darüber, welche Rolle.
Oder wie groß Fox IT in die auf diesem Camp vertreten ist.
Interessantes Detail fand ich auch, dass sie nicht nur dieses Zeug äh hier herstellen, sondern auch verkaufen und das an den ähm unter anderem äh wo an das Regime und in den Nahen Osten, dass ähm
soweit ich weiß und ich bin da auch keine Expertin, ist das nicht belegt, aber auch nie dementiert worden.
Mhm. Also es ranken sich da, ich bin da jetzt auch etwas vorsichtig. Es es ranken sich da allerlei äh üble ähm Gerüchte um diese Firma und ähm.
Also ich habe mich irgendwann dann auch mal mit Leuten von denen an ihrem Zelt unterhalten und da ähm in diesem Gespräch sind auch diese Sachen gefallen und auch das hat nicht dazu geführt, dass irgendjemand wild gesagt hätte, nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Also das ist steht so im Raum.
Nichts Genaues weiß man nicht so äh offiziell haben sie sich so ein bisschen zurückgezogen mit ja der Teil, der diesen äh diese Dinge verkauft hat, der ist äh ist ja verkauft worden und das ist ja jetzt nicht mehr so äh.
Sagt Siemens über Gamma auch, oder?
Ja, ich meine, was heißt das schon, ne? Ich meine, ich will jetzt gar nicht da ich finde das auch am Ende.
Was die jetzt genau gemacht haben oder nicht gemacht haben, das ist das eine,
ja? Das andere ist auch grundsätzlich natürlich, wie man auf solchen Veranstaltungen mit äh Sponsoring umgehen soll und was überhaupt das Verhältnis zu Firmen ist, die natürlich ab einem bestimmten Punkt.
Ähm.
Anders über Dinge nachdenken, als man das jetzt in so einer freigeistigen, unabhängigen durch das Individuum geprägten Hackerszene äh so normalerweise vorfindet.
Gibt ja auch noch einen Kritikpunkt, den du eben ausgelassen hast, äh und zwar die Präsenz der Polizei.
Genau, da wollte ich gerade zu, das war also die erste Mail dagegen es war hauptsächlich ging das um zwei Mails die auf landeten aus der internen Omorga Liste. Das erste war dann überhaupt diese,
Verquickung mit Fox IT und diese der Umgang mit Sponsoren. Ähm das Zweite war, dass dann irgend,
auf dieser Mailingliste jemand schrieb, ja, jetzt hat sich hier die Polizei gemeldet, die hätten gerne auch ein Village bei der OM
und eigentlich finde ich das ja cool, weil das sind ja Hacker wie du und ich, aber irgendwie, wenn ich mir überlege, äh was wir jetzt gerade schon für einen Ärger in der Hackers mit der deutschen Hackersze,
besondere wegen Fox IT haben, ist das vielleicht unklug,
wenn die Polizei dann noch ein eigenes Village bekommt, also Village heißt also in diese diese Camps organisieren sich in Villages, das heißt man so weiß nicht die,
die Firmenkollektive Gruppen gleichgesinnten stellen natürlich ihre Zelte zusammen und haben dann in der Regel da auch gerne noch so einen Workshopzelt, äh um da ihre.
Gemeinsam äh treffen oder oder Workshop.
Wobei für Firmen ist dieser Begriff mal nicht erfunden worden, ne?
Nee, nee, genau, aber das äh in, aber äh allein die Idee, ja, dass es eine offizielle Polizeipräsenz auf einem Camp gibt, äh glaube ich, ist der deutschen Szene,
Glücklicherweise sehr, sehr fremd und es war äh ist.
Aber auch in Holland nichts Neues in dem Sinne, ne? Also es gab auch schon mal auf der zum Beispiel.
Im Polizeizelt.
Ja, es gab da so, ich glaube, das war ein Wohnwagen. Das ist äh da, da saß dann dieser Typ, der dann später so bekannt geworden ist durch diesen großartigen Remix, der gemacht.
Hacking ist not a loud in the notherence, ja? Äh,
Der saß da irgendwie in seinem Wohnwagen. Damals gab's um diese Präsenz weniger Aufregung, als dass man das halt so zur allgemeinen Belustigung äh genutzt hat.
So muss man auch sagen, also mir ist nicht mehr so ganz genau klar, wie das da strukturiert war
die eigentliche Polizeipräsenz selber, dies da aber auch gab, war halt vor den Touren und so war's auch bei WhatsApp und ich weiß leider nicht, wie es bei der Haar war, da war ich nicht da. Also es ist halt einfach in Holland schon immer anders gewesen und es hat sich sehr viel früher schon
dramatisch äh verschärft alles.
Mein Eindruck ist, also so ist mir das auf jeden Fall erzählt worden, ist das sozusagen die die
Anwesenheit von Sicherheitsbehörden im Camp äh immer schon und sowieso auch rechtlich notwendig ist und und nie groß äh kritisiert wurde und der Unterschied dieses Jahr bei eben war, dass Village und die Sichtbarkeit und die Möglichkeit, dass die da womöglich in Uniform
rekrutieren sozusagen. Und und von Überwachung sozusagen ganz abgesehen.
Genau, naja gut, ich meine, das,
dass irgendjemand auf diesen Camps rumläuft, der irgendwo arbeitet, das war auch auf dem Kongress noch nie anders und das kann man ja in dem Sinne auch nicht verhindern. Und das ist ja auch gar nicht der Punkt. Es geht nicht darum, irgendwas zu verhindern, sondern es ging einfach in der ganzen Debatte darum,
Wie gehen wir damit um? Äh wie sehr wollen wir so etwas äh explizit fördern? Oder inwiefern machen wir da einfach auch ein und sagen, dass das ist nicht Teil unserer Kultur.
Genau, das ist, glaube ich, auch der zentrale Punkt. Also es gab ja dann irgendwann diese diese Kritikschrift von von einem Holländer namens Hunde geschrieben wird, das könnte, so aus unserer,
die einen langen Text, der ähm oder ähm sozusagen aus einer aus einer kritischen, holländischen Hackerperspektive das alles mal so ein bisschen aufdröselt,
und und ein Teil davon war eben auch, was was bedeutet das eigentlich so für unsere Selbstdefinition als Hacker-Community in den Niederlanden und wie welches Selbstverständnis haben wir da eigentlich und was ist eigentlich mit Hacker Effects und ähm
und was heißt das sozusagen für die jungen Leute, die nachwachsen, wenn für die so selbstverständlich ist, dass man für für solche Firmen arbeitet und die Polizei dabei ist und ähm,
ein bisschen mehr so quasi den kulturellen als politisch kulturellen Aspekt davon auch auch betont und sagt, dass das irgendwie das
geht so nicht, so das sind wir nicht oder sollten wir nicht sein.
Ja und ich denke, das war auch schon immer im Mittelpunkt ähm dieses Signal an die an die nachwachsende Generation, ja. Ich meine, auch im Club gab's ja häufig die Fälle
dass Leute sich äh so in den Schutzbereich des Klubs gerettet haben, nachdem sie äh Ansprache erhalten haben aus ähm kritischen,
Umgebung, Geheimdiensten, Firmen, die von Geheimdiensten betrieben werden und so weiter und dann eben nach ein paar Tests mit so ein paar Testaufträgen äh innerschlüpfigere Aufgabenstellung hinein äh geraten sind, bis sie dann halt
Kaltfüße bekommen haben und gesagt haben, ich will mich dem entziehen und dann eben auch in der Hackerszene auch
einen gewissen Schutz genießen, dadurch, dass einfach die Szene sich eben da klar dagegen stellt und sagt, bis hierhin und nicht weiter, wenn ihr jetzt der Meinung seid, ihr müsstet das äh.
Weiter vordringen in unsere Szene, dann äh äh werdet ihr das schon bereuen, ja.
Etwas profilierteren Bereich von dieser Fragestellung auch ein Panel bei der Ohren von Leuten, die früher mal bei Sicherheits ich glaube Behörden gearbeitet haben. Ich war da leider nicht.
Ähm.
Habe ich leider auch nicht gesehen.
Ich bin ich weiß nicht, ob das war, ach so, nee, das war der andere. Ich habe einen anderen gesehen. Es gab mehrere zu dem Thema. Also diese ganze ähm,
Zusammenarbeit mit den Behörden Thematik, die wurde ja dann doch noch sehr viel größer in diesem Urmumfeld, also auch wegen der vorangegangenen Debatte, ne, weil das was sich ja daraus dann ergab, war ja der Neusee Square
Also der, dass die Idee des Noise Squares eines großen Villages ähm unter dem Motto puting the resistance back in Um äh,
ergab sich ja erst durch diese durch diese Debatten, die da äh vor im Vorlauf stattgefunden haben oder.
Was mir übrigens gar nicht von Anfang an klar war, ich bin äh also wir sind als Tactical Tech eingeladen worden, uns da dran zu beteiligen und dachten, hey, das sind irgendwie nette, nette Leute und gute Organisationen, die da mitmachen und sozusagen diesen,
Ich sag mal also
Technik für den guten Zweck äh Idee dabei, die also entsprach uns sehr und und das gemeinsam als Village zu machen und mit einem eigenen Programm, das fanden wir super und dieses Pudding, der Resistance Back und da oben und dass das entstanden war
in sozusagen ähm als äh als Reaktion auf diese Debatte, das ist mir erst klar geworden, als ich da angekommen bin.
Echt, oh, krass.
Ähm das hat aber auch damit zu tun, dass wir selber ein Camp hatten ähm vier Wochen vorher und einfach unglaublichen Stress waren. Dazwischen war ich im Urlaub und ich habe
das sozusagen gar nicht so unglaublich intensiv beobachtet, was da vorher passiert ist, weil für mich war das eher so ein ich wir machen da so ein bisschen was und ansonsten ist halt ein nettes Camp, wo ich hinfahre und den Rest sehen wir mal.
Okay, jetzt wird's spannend, weil jetzt so das und auf einmal findest du dich in dieser in dieser Situation wieder quasi auf dem
in dem Village, in dem Protest Village beim Camp zu sein, was so total vorher schon aufgeladen war, ähm,
Äh viele äh,
auch expoinierte Figuren des CCC sind nicht hingegangen, haben dieses Camp boykottiert aus verschiedene.
Das ist mir natürlich auch nicht entgangen. Also ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute vorher warst, du fährst zur Om, da kann man doch nicht hinfahren. Warum machst du das? Und ähm klar, das war nicht zu übersehen.
Also ich weiß, ähm.
Ich habe dann bei der Republika kam dann so erstmals die Idee auf der Weine dann auch einige äh internationale äh Hacker, mit denen man sich so unterhalten hat. Da kam dann so langsam diese Idee auf, da war nämlich genau grade die Thematik, so gehen wir gehen wir hin.
Oder boykottieren wir und dann hieß es natürlich, ey, wenn wir, wenn wir alle boykottieren, werden wir nicht gehört. Also äh genau den anderen Weg
und denen einfach mal zeigen, wo's langgeht. Und das war schon auch so die die Stimmung, mit der man dahingefahren ist. Also ähm,
Es war klar.
Dass es da das war einfach aufgeladen, ja? Und man ist da hingegangen, obwohl man quasi etwas gegen die Veranstalter hatte. So.
Für mich war das auch ein Punkt war, war schon auch Neugierde, weil, wie gesagt, ich ich habe das nicht intensiv verfolgt. Ich habe irgendwann im März, April diesen kleinen Wirbel da drum mitgekriegt. Dann habe ich mitgekriegt, viele Leute fahren nicht hin, dann habe ich mal,
ohne dass eine ausgiebige Recherche zu machen geguckt, gibt's denn da jetzt irgendwie mal irgendwas, gibt es einen Balkottaufruf, gibt es irgendwas, irgendwo
flog bei mir vorbei und ist irgendwer in der Schweiz ein Alternativcamp machen will, habe ich dann aber auch nicht mehr gesehen. Ich habe im Grunde nichts mehr dazu gefunden. Das hat mich öffentlich stattgefunden oder auch nur halböffentlich, sodass man irgendwie sich damit hätte auseinandersetzen können,
Und das war auch für mich ein Grund dahinzufahren, zu denken, okay, dann ähm diskutieren wir das da. Dann hoffe
da einfach mal ein bisschen darüber rausfinden. Ich war ziemlich überrascht, als ich mir das Programm angeguckt habe, dass da quasi fast nichts zu drin war. Also ja, natürlich gab's irgendwie und da so so Panels, wie wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe. Ähm und dann gab es eins.
Was quasi diese Kontroverse ansprach, wo ursprünglich jemand von FOX IT mit auf dem Podium sitzen sollte und dann aber doch nicht saß und ähm,
Also dieses eine Penner und mehr nicht. Da habe ich echt gestaunt, weil ich dachte, ich dachte, wir sind hier um über genau diese Fragen zu diskutieren und ähm das hat dann zwar informell viel stattgefunden, aber aber,
organisiert in irgendeiner Form erstmal nicht. Wir haben dann im Quer noch so eine Diskussion angesetzt. Äh ziemlich spontan, auch nur eine Stunde, weil im Programm gar keine Zeit mehr war und das würde ich sagen, fand ich ähm,
fand ich echt nicht gut, dass das nicht mehr besprochen wurde.
Diese Diskussion am wie äh wer hat sich da jemand von dran beteiligt?
Oberhölle. Also ähm,
Ja, das also die Auseinandersetzung schön und und da oben Orga und gleich Fox IT im Grunde, die die waren ähm also.
Waren auf jeden Fall sehr merkbar vorhanden. Wir haben diese Diskussion eigentlich,
er, wie gesagt, so so ganz spontan, wir müssen da jetzt mal und sei es nur als Neuss quer untereinander nochmal drüber reden. Dieser, das, das ist irgendwie nötig als äh politische Hygiene, wenn man so will, dass,
dass das besprochen wird, was wir eigentlich davon halten und was mit diesen Boykott-Aufforderungen ist und wie das in Zukunft alles weitergehen soll, haben das ins Programm geschrieben
und am Abend vorher, wir hatten jeden Abend so ein kurzes äh im Grunde Orga-Treffen, wer macht nächsten Tag die
Bar und äh wer macht die Bühnenmoderation und gibt's noch irgendwas zu besprechen? Und da tauchte dann unter anderem Kuhn auf und ähm Fox IT und und Omorga und
haben uns damit konfrontiert, dass es,
offensichtlich zwischenzeitlich riesen Probleme zwischen und Ohm gab, von denen ich absolut gar nichts mitgekriegt habe, aber das haben natürlich die neunzig Querleute, die das organisiert haben, also die Holländer, die die das tatsächlich
ähm in der Hand hatten. Die haben davon sehr viel mehr abgekriegt.
Und da gab es dann einen sogenannten Incident, wo was vorgefallen war, was sich im Laufe von vierundzwanzig Stunden zu einer Riesenstory aufgebauscht hat,
gar nicht wahr. Ähm die tauchten dann also bei diesem dieser Versammlung auf, forderten ein Statement oder eine Entschuldigung vom gesamten Neusis-Quer, der saß da drin und da ist genau in der Nacht.
Der war folgendes, es gab da so so Golfcards, die durch die Gegend fuhren, die Leute transportiert haben und irgendwann am ersten Tag,
fuhr so ein Ding.
Ganz kurz zu den Golfcuts. Die Golf Cuts gehörten, also du hattest ein Golfcard, wenn du eine bestimmten Sponsorstatus hattest. Ja, also als Sponsor, es gab irgendwie drei Golfcuts, die gehörten dann dem, die weiß ich nicht, den Müll
Jungs, die sich um den Müll gekümmert haben, so also für die Orga gab's irgendwie drei Golfcards oder so. Und ähm ein
Gold, Silber oder Bronzesponsor hatte auch einen Kart. Ja, also diese ganze Sponsorpolicy, die du gerade ansprichst, ähm,
spielte da auch rein. Als größerer Sponsor dieses Camps, ja, wo du natürlich dann sowieso dein eigenes Zelt hattest, wo deine Plane dranhängen, mit deiner Werbung, ob das jetzt Deloitte oder oder Fox ITVer und diese Golfcards gab's eben auch.
Fox IT hatte natürlich auch einen Golfcard.
Genau und dieses Ding fuhr also so in in Richtung Neusiß quer und hat.
Mit Fox IT.
Großem Fox IT-Logo ähm vorne auf der Windschutzscheibe,
bewegte sich somit irgendwie 'ne Frau am Steuer und 'nem Typ mit 'ner großen Kamera in unsere Richtung und wir wir hingen da so in der Sonne rum, war ja schön, ne warte mal, am nächsten Tag war ja gar nicht so, nee, keine Ahnung, jedenfalls waren wir da und ähm,
was jemand zum mitgebracht hatte, war, also Absperrband, ähm schwarz-gelb gestreift. Normalerweise.
Line, Donald Tross.
Genau und da stand aber drauf. Ähm das war der kleine Unterschied und dann haben wir Leute, welche dieses Band genommen haben, dieses Golfcard, was da sehr langsam sich vorwärts bewegte, ähm haben sich da vorgestellt und haben zweimal dieses gelbe Band um die Windschutzscheibe gewickelt.
Nicht um die also um den Teil, wo dieses äh.
Fox IT draufstand. Genau, also nicht komplett zugemacht, sondern so. Dann war das Logo halt weg. Ähm,
irgendwie weiß ich nicht, kurzes Geplänkel, nicht laut, also die Leute da standen, da hielten sich natürlich, ich war zwei Meter weg und habe ein Foto davon gemacht und ähm dann fuhren die wieder weg.
Damit irgendwie war das für mich gegessen. Am nächsten Abend, wie gesagt, also Fox IT ähm im Generalsemi von Neusi's quer, riesen Aufregung, die die des Camps, also des Ereignis
und äh es braucht jetzt ein Statement und irgendwas und viele wussten nicht, was jetzt eigentlich los ist und worum es geht, andere schon und diese Geschichte hatte sich voll aufgebauscht,
unterschiedliche Richtungen und verschiedene Versionen davon sind, dass zehn bis fünfzehn aggressive Männer ähm die Frau überfallen haben.
Aus dem Auto raus gezerrt, habe ich gehört. Ja, ja.
Eier? Okay, ähm also das Ganze soll teilweise hat sich das auch drei Uhr morgens in der Nacht ähm bewegt und ähm das Golf Card soll in irgendeinem dieser Gräben gelandet sein. Ähm.
Okay, da gibt's dann, es ist Golfcard, wurde tatsächlich auch noch gestohlen, ja? Das.
Noch, es gibt ein anderes, es gibt noch ein anderes, es gibt noch eine andere Geschichte mit einem Golfcard. Ich weiß nicht, ob das dieses war, aber irgendeins ist, glaube ich, in der Zeit auch geklaut worden.
Ja, ja, da haben sich nämlich dann diese beiden Geschichten haben sich nämlich gemischt.
Vermischt. Das ist dann auch dem gleich angehängt worden, wobei später rauskam, dass das, ich weiß gar nicht.
Betrunkenen Briten oder so.
Es haben also dieses geklaute Golfcard äh ich könnte jetzt mal kurz im Chat fragen, wie das genau war, aber ich weiß, dass ein ein äh Freund von mir, dass dann quasi denen, die es tatsächlich geklaut haben,
dass quasi auch wieder geklaut hat und das dann zum.
Hatten viele Leute viel Spaß.
Golfcut war auf jeden Fall vakant. Und irgendwann wurde einer damit erwischt.
Aber jedenfalls, wer wer überhaupt keinen Spaß hatte, war also Kuhn von der Omorga, der bei uns im Zelt saß und unglaublich aggressiv irgendwie ihr habt doch bei uns das Graffiti gesprüht in der Nacht, das hat auch irgendjemand rot, NSA auf das Fox IT.
Äh das war jetzt nicht die coolste Aktion der Veranstaltung, aber.
Ähm äh also wo ich sagen würde, ey, also wenn wir's gewesen wären, dann hätte das nicht so ausgesehen, ja, das war für mich,
hässlich, wie das hinterher aussah. Ähm und ähm außerdem wollt ihr, werdet ihr heute Nacht unser Zelt angreifen, also in aggressivem Ton, so in die gesamte Runde von, ich weiß nicht, da waren vierzig, fünfzig, sechzig Leute in diesem Zelt, die zum Teil
vollkommen ahnungslos waren, was hier eigentlich los war, weil.
Malt er denn mit unser Zelt?
IT-Zelte.
Also da hat er schon als Probenorganisator.
Ja ja, der saß auch mit Fox IT T-Shirt saß der da. Ja, ja. Ähm und, und, ne?
Kuhn ist doch der Geschäftsführer von FOX IT oder täusch ich mich da jetzt.
Weiß ich überhaupt nicht.
Äh
Arbeitet da, aber das.
Fand ich, fand ich schon sehr irre, das war eine echt heftige Dynamik zwischen zwischen Neusia Organisation, Holländer und, und, und
um und Fox IT, auch Holländer und da waren ja aber zu achtzig Prozent Leute, die keine Holländer sind, diese Dynamik gar nicht kennen, die von all dem nichts mitgekriegt haben und halt diese, ich glaube, zwölf verschiedenen Organisationen, die gemeinsam Neusis quer waren, ähm,
Ähm völlig baff erstmal von dem, was hier eigentlich los ist. Der hat, der hat gebrüllt, der hat dann das Mikro durchs Zelt geschleudert. Ähm mehrfach äh.
Bitte, oh Mann.
Äh ganz kurz.
Also es gab dann auch, es hat auch abgeseits von dieser Versammlung Drohungen gegeben, Neuss sich quer den Strom abzustellen, uns komplett zu räumen, Zitat, ich habe hier irgendwie monatelang gearbeitet, ich habe das hier alles organisiert, wenn ich will, kann ich das hier auch beenden, wo
dem Punkto total klar war, der ist drüber, ja, der ist sozusagen totaler Burnout, der ist einfach wirklich nicht mehr so richtig bei sich. Ähm das ist nicht
gut, was hier gerade stattfindet. Glücklicherweise würde ich sagen, haben alle anderen Leute in dem Zelt, das glaube ich, in irgendeiner Weise realisiert, dass
also erstens wollte sich ja niemand streiten und wollte sich jetzt niemand mit mir groß beschmeißen und wir wollten das irgendwie in den Griff kriegen, was hier stattfindet und zweitens war aber auch total deutlich, der ist einfach nicht mehr so richtig
bei sich, der ist gar nicht in der Lage das zu händeln, also wenn wenn ein Camp-Organisator plötzlich ankommt, mit, das ist mein Camp und wenn ich will, kann ich euch hier rausschmeißen, dann weißt du da,
den schickst du jetzt einfach am besten ins Bett oder so irgendwie.
Dann läuft der auch noch mit dem mit dem Firmen-T-Shirt durch die Gegend, also jetzt jetzt ach so, jetzt schalte ich auch langsam ab, also es ist äh wie.
Dann wurde halt dieser Installent besprochen, äh derjenige, der einer von denen, die da dran beteiligt waren, hat, fand ich sehr cool und auch sehr mutig, äh sozusagen in der Situation gesagt, hier ich war's, ja, also was was das sofort ziemlich,
ich ich habe,
Band da drum gewickelt. Ich ich war derjenige, der hier vorgeworfen wird, die Frau irgendwie äh und so weiter. Also irgendwie Assorte zu haben, was ja ein bisschen doppeldeutig ist im Englischen angegriffen zu haben und ähm ich hat dann seine,
davon beschrieben, äh dass das eben da dieses Band drum gewickelt wurde und sonst gar nicht stattgefunden hat,
dass er ansonsten vollkommen dazu steht ähm und dass deswegen ja auch existiert als gewissermaßen Protest gegen gegen die Präsenz von FOX IT im Camp und äh dass das deswegen.
Also Erfolg dazu steht, da so ein Band drum zu wickeln, was ja jetzt niemandem wehtut. Ähm.
In den Links äh zu dieser Sendung gibt's ein schönes Foto, wie diese Frau lachend äh da sitzt, während ihr Golfcard eingesammelt.
In meinem Foto lacht sie nicht, was auch dazu. Das ist mir dann auch von verschiedenen Holländern bestätigt worden. Die war selber wohl ziemlich im Stress. Die hatte vorher schon irgendeinen Zusammenbruch gehabt. Ähm und und äh muss das ziemlich heftig genommen haben. Ich
weiß nicht ganz genau wie, aber also dass die davon Stress hatte und hinterher davon sozusagen zusätzlich gestresst war, das das will ich jetzt überhaupt nicht in Abrede stellen, auch wenn sie gelacht hat auf dem Foto, aber das
natürlich.
Die andere Mitarbeiterin von und die beiden äh waren standen sozusagen auch in der ganzen Debatte auch immer im Mittelpunkt und diese persönliche Auseinandersetzung also dieser persönliche Level, den das dadurch,
zwangsläufig natürlich auch für sie bekamen. Ich denke, das hat dann auch nochmal extra an den Nerven äh.
Genau, das das will ich nicht abreden. Das sozusagen tut uns natürlich leid, aber das war natürlich nicht beabsichtigt und, und, und nicht vorherzusehen, dass das diese diese.
Vor allem am Ende nicht mehr zu ändern. Also ich meine, die Geister, die ich rief, kann ich dazu nur sagen, ja, ich meine, äh die mögen ja die besten Absichten gehabt haben. Ja, aber.
Es ist ja auch viel gesagt worden. Es ist auch immer wieder nach nach freiwilligen äh gerufen worden, dass die einen unglaublichen Mangel an Leuten hatten, die die die da mithelfen, was auch
erklärt wurde. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt wirklich ausschlaggebend oder der alleinige Grund war, aber damit war, dass wenn du Fox IT als Sponsor hast, viele Leute natürlich sagen, ja, krümme ich keinen Finger für.
Ja, ja, das habe ich auch von einigen gehört, ja.
Also Mangel an äh an Freiwilligen gibt's ja einen, also eklatanten Mangel an Freiwilligen gibt's bei CCC Veranstaltungen nicht.
Und und das dann entsprechend die Leute irgendwann im Burnout enden, die das organisieren, das ist nicht überraschend, äh aber ärgerlich natürlich.
Walten. Mal ganz kurz, Kuhm ist nicht äh nirgendwo im Management oder Director bei hier hast du recht. Äh der ist äh Developer für äh Kryptokram. Ähm hat aber, glaube ich, wenn ich das,
Zweiter Anlauf mit Halbwissen, der war aber doch so, also der war hauptsächlich einer der Hauptorganisatoren, Organisatoren herum und war dafür natürlich auch beruflich.
Gestellt worden, ja? Ähm jetzt geht also diese.
Hackerfirma hin, sagt, ey, wir richten dieses geile Camp aus, wir sind so eine coole Firma, wir sind so ein cooles Team, wir haben echt was drauf. Ich meine, wenn man sich anguckt, was die für Interset-Sachen machen, haben die auch was drauf. Ähm und sagen, wir schaffen jetzt diesen,
Trauben, dieses Hackercamp, ja, was nur alle vier Jahre gibt, was immer
irgendwie natürlich so ein ein historisches Teil ist, ja, weil es eben nur alle vier Jahre stattfindet und wir wir machen das. Und man denkt so, man geht da irgendwie rein und sagt
Egal und weil wir so eine coole Firma sind, sponsern wir das sogar, ne? Und äh schenken das jetzt quasi der Hacker-Szene, ja? Und ähm.
Am zweiten Tag hast du auf einmal äh an deinen an deinem Zelt NSA dranstehen und du hast da so ein Anarchisten-Camp am anderen Ende. Das war ja auch noch das Spannende. Der war ja genau am anderen Ende dieses
ohnehin sehr weitläufigen Camps, ja, also alle coolen Leute waren genau am anderen Ende so ungefähr. Ähm,
und dieses gesamte Ding, wofür die ja sicherlich, du du Tim weißt das ja besser als äh als Anne oder ich, wie viel Orga es ist so ein Camp,
aufzustellen. Das machste nicht in ein paar Monaten. Das machst du über Jahre und dann ein paar Monate äh sechzig Stunden die Woche ungefähr. Würde ich jetzt mal so schätzen,
und.
Um es jetzt mal ein bisschen vorwegzunehmen, wenn ich mir diese ganze Arbeit gemacht hätte und da wäre am Ende diese Scheißveranstaltung bei rausgekommen, wo ich noch sehr viel mehr Kritik dran habe, außer, dass irgendwie Fox IT Dark äh gesponsert hat, ja?
Noch über das Essen und dann mein Essen war super, wir haben.
Mein Essen war super, wir haben selber gekocht, ja? Also.
Ja, was ist dann?
Ja, was ist dann? Ja, wir auch.
Dann würde ich auch einen Nervenzusammenbruch kriegen, weil diese Veranstaltung, also ist schon jetzt platzt aus mir raus, war der Tiefpunkt.
Ja, also ich habe, ich habe, ich habe ja das zweite Camp gemacht und da war alles toll und ich habe einen Nervenzusammenbruch bekommen. Also das das geht schon viel, viel früher los, ja.
Weil du bist da einfach ähm das ist so eine, man ist auch die Herausforderung, ja, aber diese Hackerszene,
Das ist so eine intensive,
Szene, weil die einfach so krass voll ist mit so viel brillanten Hirnen und und Wahnsinnigen und und auch zum außergewöhnlichen immer bereit seinden Menschen,
So, ich meine, man muss sich doch nur mal diese Infrastruktur anschaffen, äh, anschauen, die im Rahmen dieser Veranstaltung geschaffen wird. Das ist doch schon total absurd.
Fand ich jetzt da überhaupt nicht mehr absurd, bei in den Fino Foodcamps fand ich's absurd, aber.
Ja, man gewöhnt sich langsam,
da dran, dass es natürlich irgendwie vollkommen normal ist, dass da erstmal mit äh äh professionellen Baggermaschinen äh erstmal ein paar Kilometer Glasfaserkabel verlegt werden aufm Acker
ja? Für uns ist das normal, aber ja äh vielleicht haben wir uns auch schon dran gewöhnt, dass jede durchschnittliche CCC Veranstaltung mit ihrem eigenen GSM-Netz äh daherkommen.
Die Holländer übrigens nicht, fand ich schwach.
Nee, hatten sie nicht. Siehste mal. Ist das denn hier? Mein eigenes GS.
Naja, ich äh habe aus beruflichem Interesse durchaus nicht auf das GSM-Netz gefre.
Na ja, so, aber ich sage nur, die die Standards sind da auch äh extrem
angestiegen, ne? Aber es ist halt einfach, du hast es einfach mit einer Szene zu tun, die ist, die ist zu einer Menge fähig und natürlich willst du auch eine Menge äh machen so, aber es sind natürlich auch alles
Leute, mit denen man sich gut reiben kann. Und wenn man da eben für sich selber nicht ein extrem gutes Kräftemanagement an Start bringt und das hat viel mit Erfahrung zu tun,
Dann reibt man sich da schnell auf, ja? Also das ist vollkommen normal.
Auf einmal und dann hast du jetzt als oben Organisator auf einmal ungefähr tausend bis zweitausend Leute, die.
Alles, was du als deine Identität auffasst, nämlich irgendwie für diese Firma zu arbeiten und dieses Camp zu machen.
Grund heraus ablehnen. Ja und das macht's dir nicht einfacher.
Sicher, dass es so viele sind, weil also.
Also ich weiß es überhaupt gar nicht, aber ich habe auch mit vielen Leuten gesprochen, die das jetzt kein Problem fanden.
Hm okay, also gefühlt auf jeden Fall mit einem starken Gegenwind, ja, allein schon dieser ganze.
Man muss auch sagen, dass die große Empörung ist natürlich ein sehr deutsches Phänomen, ja,
äh hat sich jetzt so in den anderen Ländern so nicht wiedergeschlagen und natürlich äh lief der Graben da auch ganz deutlich zwischen der holländischen und der deutschen Szene und auch deren Perspektive ähm
gibt's da halt auch so einige Enttäuschungen, ja, also weil die eben auch teilweise äh die Reaktionen als überzogen ansehen und äh immer wieder Unterschiede auch anmahnen, die halt einfach kulturell
da äh vorhanden sind. Das würde ich auch niemals bestreiten, das war auch schon immer so ein bisschen so, ne.
Also mir hat das übrigens, wir haben dann am nächsten Tag ja diese Debatte tatsächlich gehabt und in kleinen Gruppen über das Problem gesprochen und in meiner kleinen Gruppe waren mehrere Holländer, die das so erklärt haben. Ähm
nicht überraschend, aber ich fand's trotzdem aufschlussreich, dass dass eben diese politische Kultur des Umgangs mit der Polizei
in der holländischen Hackerszene eine andere ist. Ich denke, dass es da auch Ausnahmen gibt, aber die damit zu tun hat, dass beispielsweise
Wir in Holland, Zitat, ähm wir lassen halt die Polizei auch in unsere Coffeeshops und in den Red Light District, damit die gucken können, dass alles in Ordnung ist. Ähm wir schließen die nicht aus, sondern wir laden die immer ein zu kommen und das ist eben unser Verhältnis
dazu, dass,
Wie gesagt, ich denke, dass irgendwie die die besetzten Häuser früher in Amsterdam das nicht so gehandhabt haben und dass es auch Teile der holländischen Hacker gibt, die das anders sehen, aber das ist auf jeden Fall offensichtlich ein ein
akzeptierte eine weit akzeptierte Sichtweise im Umgang mit sowas, das ist einfach anders als bei uns.
Lärm,
Genau, das darauf wollte ich nämlich eigentlich hinaus. Es ist anders und ähm das muss man hier auf jeden Fall auch noch mit einpreisen. Nichtsdestotrotz finde ich,
Die Art und Weise, wie insbesondere mit Sponsorings äh umgegangen wird und ganz konkret jetzt, wie auch das mit dem FOX IT gelaufen ist, finde ich einfach äh falsch,
Ich denke, man muss da schon klarer trennen zwischen der Community,
ja? Und dem, was äh die Regeln einer Businesswelt sind. Und mein Verständnis solcher Events war auch immer.
Wenn du da bist, bist du,
bist du in so einem Zauberwald. Ja, da bist du in so einem, so, so ein, so einem, so ein Paradies, der Glücklichen und da wird dann auch mal ein bisschen das Ideal äh ordentlich durch den Wald getrieben,
Äh und das kann natürlich nur dann gelingen, wenn du eben auch wirklich weitgehend entkoppelt bist von all dem, was dich sonst eben zurückhält.
Dass man das auch einfach mal ausleben kann. Aber in dem Moment, wo so eine so eine Hauptstraße auf so einem Camp, ja,
ist von Firmenlogos und du da irgendwie von Zell zu Zelt durchmarschierst und dann sitzen sie da alle mit ihrem gesponserten Puls äh in ihren gesponserten Getränken, die sie aus gesponserten Kühlschränken rausgeholt haben, in
gesponserten Freizeit von ihrem Unternehmen. Ähm mit ihren gesponserten Tickets, was weiß ich, ja, wo ich auch gar nichts.
Ich auch gar nichts gegen habe so, aber warum können sie dann bitte nicht einfach dieses Corporate äh äh Ding an der Stelle eigentlich auch einfach zu Hause lassen oder am Eingang zumindest mal abgeben,
und sagen, okay, wir sind jetzt hier auch als äh Individuen, weil sich das eben dann häufig auch tatsächlich so entwickelt, dass eben diese dieser Wettbewerb dann in diese Veranstaltung auch reingetragen wird, ja? Nicht selten dürften da auch Chefs vor Ort gewesen sein, die dann eben, was weiß ich, ja, dann das Mitarbeiterspiel
Hierarchien und Zwingen äh auch dann auf dieser Veranstaltung noch weiter spielen. Und äh,
dann ist das einfach kein Urlaub mehr und dann ist das einfach kein kein,
kein Ort des äh freien Denkens mehr und an der Stelle muss man dann sich einfach zurückhalten, aber wenn man sich auf Sponsor Deals einlässt, ich meine, ist mindestens ein Golfkatz, finde ich jetzt auch für dich, versuche ab.
Ja, das ist auch so Geld ist Privileg, ja. Das das ist eigentlich genau das, was da drin steht. Ich meine, entweder äh jemand will so eine Veranstaltung sponsern
gerne machen, so, dann soll er bitte das Geld auf den äh Tisch legen oder äh Sachmittel bereitstellen oder so, ja, das was sowieso das Wichtigste ist, mein Geld hilft auch, so ist es nicht. Auch eine Freistellung von Mitarbeitern,
hilft auch, ja und ich habe ja auch gar nichts dagegen, dass man irgendwo Sponsoren nennt,
Ja, aber wenn du dann wirklich dann schon mit diesem Platinum Gold äh Sponsor-Ding ankommst und äh große äh Anzeigen in deinen
äh deinen Flyer da äh äh reinmachst und dann diese visuelle Präsenz sich auch so weit äh,
in die Sinnlosigkeit steigert, also wo ich dann komplett hinten umgefallen bin, ist als sie dann angefangen haben mit ihrem Scheiß Laser, ihr Fox-IT-Logo auch noch auf das nachts auch noch auf dieses Hauptzelt drauf zu projiz
ja? Also äh da war dann bei mir dann auch jegliches Verständnis für wir machen das anders in Holland, war dann irgendwie auch äh ein so ein Ende gekommen.
Glücklicherweise war ja tatsächlich das wirklich weit weg und ich meine, das klingt jetzt aus, als wäre es alles total super schrecklich gewesen. Ich unterschreibe alles, was du sagst, aber ich muss sagen, für mich war das Camp insgesamt trotzdem total cool. Also ich habe mich da in,
unterm Strich sehr wohl gefühlt.
Da sage ich gleich nochmal was.
Also im im Neusis Querbereich sozusagen. Das war einfach so nette, kleine, freie, autonome Zone von sehr coolen Leuten, sehr coolen Organisationen, wo eine Menge angestoßen wurde und viel stattgefunden hat. Also ich hatte da.
Dieser dieser Neusi Square, der war sozusagen das eigentliche Camp. Ja. So ein bisschen, ne.
Ja ja der der neue war das eigentliche Camp.
Ja, das gehörte auf jeden Fall. Ja.
Ja, ja, die hat das mit dem Noisy natürlich wie immer ein bisschen zu ernst genommen.
Äh das das die zum Schluss noch irgendwie äh mit Hunden.
Diese Geschichte. Die Geschichte ist der Hammer.
Hunde, Hunde aufm.
Italien Embassy spielt irgendwie Kirmestechno vom vom Feinsten und und gießen sich den Grappa in den Hals und nachts um drei.
Und zwar rund um die Uhr.
Und und irgendwie, die hatten ja auch so eine Art Open-Mice zu diesem äh zu diesem zu diesem Techno-Ding. Ich meine, weißt du da, als die Hunde kamen?
Nee, ich war gerade im Bett. Ich habe das Hundegebell gehört und gedacht, was ist das denn? Es gibt doch keine Hunde aufm Kind, muss ich mir jetzt Sorgen machen und dann bin ich aber eingeschlafen.
Und das waren halt, also das war die Polizei. Die Polizei kam mit Hunden und wollte halt irgendwie nachts um drei dann irgendwie mal dafür sorgen, dass da jetzt.
Ruhestörung beendet wird.
Einkehrt, ja?
Auftrage von wem?
Camp Security. Also mir ist das berichtet worden, als die Camp Security sei das gewesen, die sozusagen erst versucht haben wegen Beschwerden von Anwohnern, soweit kann ich das,
ich noch nachvollziehen, zu sagen, hier jetzt irgendwie, das ist zu laut, das geht so nicht und ähm,
Italien Embassy, Italiener, ja, irgendwie Barrikaden gebaut und es gab eine Auseinandersetzung. Ähm,
da da würde ich sozusagen, ich war da nicht dabei, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was abgelaufen ist. Ich persönlich kann irgendwie nachvollziehen, dass Leute da ein Ruhebedürfnis hatten und die sind dann aber mit Hunden wiedergekommen.
Du, der, die kamen wieder und,
also was dann passierte war, du hättest halt dieses Italien Amnesty Zelt, ne, mit diese mit diesen absolut unerträglichen Kirmes Techno, ja? Da drin Licht an, also es war, ich meine, das ist echt eine eine Herausforderung für das Nervenkostüm, dieses dieses
und alles, was du hast, ist irgendwie wie einer zum Mikrofon geht und sagt.
Becafle.
Und die Mucke geht einfach.
Oha.
Und äh ich weiß nicht, wie das dann endete, aber so.
Das ist deeskaliert worden und die Hunde sind äh sozusagen nicht von der Leine gelassen worden. Das ist das, was ich dazu gehört habe.
Aber so diese Durchsage, der coming with dogs, becare.
Aber das war schon auch noch mal so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein i-Tüpfelchen da oben drauf, das das irgendwie in einem Camp mit Hunden irgendwer zur Strecke gebracht werden soll.
Auweia.
Vielleicht nochmal so ein ich glaube diese dieser dieses Spannungsfeld ist äh wurde nicht aufgelöst, sondern ist eher eskaliert zwischen halt irgendwie den.
Sage ich mal, der der Liberation Front und der wir arbeiten mit dem Staat zusammen. Front, das hat, glaube ich, keinerlei guten Auskander genommen.
Dieser Konflikt schwebte für mich schon auch relativ stark über dem über dem Camp. Dieser Sponsoring Sache hatte Tim jetzt auch schon so angesprochen. Ähm.
Ich bin am Montag dort angekommen.
In großer Sorge, dass wir unseren, unser Village nicht mehr oder unseren wir hatten keinen aber so unseren Platz, den wir so für uns beansprachen wollten mit den Zelten und dem,
Was wir so aufbauen wollten, ich hatte große Sorge, dass wir es nicht mehr schaffen, weil das Camp ging ja immerhin am Mittwoch los und es erschien mir naheliegend, dass man sich Montag, Dienstag mit freinimmt und bereits am Samstag anreist.
Und deswegen war ich halt in großer Sorge, dass äh dass wir irgendwie gar keinen Platz mehr finden,
ähm diese Sorge äh war äh war völlig unbegründet, als wir dann am Montag da ankamen, war das Ding größtenteils noch leer. Überall standen diese weißen,
gleichförmigen ähm Workshopzelte, die man ja für dreihundertfünfundsiebzig Euro oder was dann sich da vorbestellen konnte. Ähm.
Was mich auch sehr wundert und das ganze Ding also sehr äh seelenlos erschienen ließ für mich. Ähm und am Füllstand dieses Camps änderte sich dann eigentlich nicht mehr großartig was. Also es hatte,
viel zu viel Fläche.
Für diese Anzahl Personen, was denn daran lag, wie ich nachher oder wie ich dann relativ bald erfuhr, dass äh in Holland die Bürokratie ein äh in voller Blüte steht und es außerdem ja einige
Vorkommnisse bei Großveranstaltungen gab, die zu einer sehr großen Regulation in dem Bereich geführt haben, so dass die quasi anfänglich ihre ganzen,
Ihre ganzen Permits irgendwie für äh für dreieinhalbtausend Leute ausgestellt bekommen haben und als ihnen dann einfiel, ey wir könnten auf fünf äh wäre das quasi, war es nicht mehr bürokratisch nicht mehr möglich, dass äh.
Zum vernünftigen Preis diese Permits alle zu ändern. Zumal die dann sagten, ach so, ähm ach so, ihr wollt tausend Leute mehr? Na ja, pro tausend Leute wisst ihr ja so und so viele Ordner,
und diese Ordner könnt ihr nicht selber stellen, sondern die müssen von einem zertifizierten Security-Dienstleister sein, ne, der also die Gelddruckmaschine, äh Großveranstaltungs äh Security, äh
Zertifikat hat
und ähm da braucht ihr so und so viele Duschen. Ach und wie, wann wollt, wann hört ihr denn mit dem Alkohol Ausschank auf? Wie die dürfen da ihren eigenen Alkohol mitbringen? Also es muss ein großer Albtraum gewesen sein und äh man munkelt davon so fünfundzwanzig bis dreißig Prozent des Budgets und,
in sowohl finanziell als auch Zeit, die für Behörden äh da drauf gehen. Ähm,
Also das noch, das noch dazu auf jeden Fall. Auf einmal, weil dieses riesige Camp und du hattest immer den Eindruck, dass es leer ist, weil es sich zu sehr verteilt hat auf dieser Fläche, ja, also,
Es hatte, wie du schon sagst, dieses dieses Zauberwaldfeeling war einfach nicht da, also es war
ja wie ein Campingplatz, wo halt auch so paar hundert Meter weiter ist halt nochmal ein Village von den und den Hackern, die können wir mal besuchen. Äh es war wirklich eine für mich war's eine,
eine richtig harte Enttäuschung, muss ich echt sagen. Ich dieses Kämpfer für mich eine eine es war trotzdem noch cool so, ja, war cool, aber.
Als Höhepunkt des Sommers, ja war das für mich eine, war das für mich eine riesige Enttäuschung und da muss man noch dazu sagen, ähm,
Ich glaube am ersten Tag des Camps ähm war die Urteilsverkündung für Bradley Manning, wenn ich das jetzt nicht äh, wenn ich mich das jetzt wenn ich das jetzt nicht,
täusche. Und abends dann
Keynote oder oder eine Stunde Ansprache von Julian Assange über Skype, ja? Und du bist dann in diesem Hauptzelt, diesem professionellen Hauptzelt, was sie sich da hingeknallt haben und da ist dann da Studien auf seinem ähm.
Auf diesen Beamer und hält da einen dermaßenen Trantütenvortrag, dass ich, wir haben's nicht geschafft, zuzuhören,
die Leute sind gegangen, das konnte sie nicht antun. Ich bin da hingegangen und habe gedacht, okay, jetzt Freunde, Messe, ja.
Ist, jetzt wird hier die die Revolution ausgerufen, jetzt knallt das hier richtig und dann machen wir die Fackeln an und ziehen los, ja? Ich habe echt gedacht, so jetzt, nee, also weißt du, ich habe.
Und machen Alkmaar platt.
Ja und wenn es nur das.
Heute Alkmaar, morgen das Sonnensystem.
Weiße Snowden hängt's zu äh hängt zu dem Zeitpunkt dann noch in dem Flughafen. Ähm Manning, ja die ist alles, ja,
und und dann sitzt Julia und sagt, ja äh,
machen uns fertig, weil wir stark sind, wir sind die einzige Gefahr, Whistleblower und Hacker sind die einzige Gefahr, die es noch gibt und deswegen vergammele ich jetzt hier in der Botschaft. Und ähm,
Und dann fragte dann irgendwie jemand so, ja, was machen wir, ne? Und er sagte so, ja, das Einzige, was mir jetzt in Anbetracht dieses Überwachungsskandals einfällt, ist, ist,
starke Kryptographie, wirklich starke Kryptographie und denkst dir nur so.
Heiland. Heiland habe ich mir gedacht, was machen wir,
Ich bin wirklich bin, ich bin da rausgegangen, ich war völlig außer mir, ich war, ich war richtig also es war so eine Enttäuschung, ja. Ich meine, dieser ganze NSA-Ding und so und dann Camp in Holland und dann so eine, so eine Vorstellung da, ich war wirklich völlig,
Also.
Vor allem, was ich auch so absurd fand, also er hat das Ganze vor so einem Blues Creen gemacht, wo dann die ganze Zeit
dieses Wiki-Leaks Logo animiert, eingeblendet wurde in so einem hypnotischen Getropfer die ganze Zeit, äh halt neben ihm so vor sich hin blubberte, wurde auch schon bekloppt wurdest, dann hat er so undeutlich gesprochen,
war auch einfach akustisch keine Freude und ähm ja, also wie du schon sagst, da kam einfach irgendwie keinerlei,
Feuer irgendwie rüber, ne? Also es war schwierig.
Und dann wollte er ja, dass die dass sein Talk nicht aufgezeichnet wird.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das stimmt nicht. Die Veranstalter, also Nick,
hat dann bei der Ankündigung gesagt, dass unter keinen Umständen Fotos und Aufzeichnungen dieses Talks gemacht werden dürfen, sollen oder was auch immer und Julian hat direkt zu Beginn gesagt, ja, dass er das jetzt gerade gehört hat, dass das gesagt wurde und dass er damit nix zu tun hat
Und das äh dass er diese Polic, das war das Erste, was er gesagt hat, ja. Aber auch geil.
Kommt denn dann diese Polici her?
Man auch nicht oft. Ist mir auch egal, das wollte doch, das will doch eh keiner aufzeichnen. Was willst du denn damit? Das ist doch vergeude.
Ja, aber ich fand das so geil, weil das Ganze lief doch über Skype oder nicht?
Ja, das haben wir.
Das heißt, die NSA darf es aufzeichnen, aber die anderen, die.
Es war, also das ist mir egal, weil das äh wer es aufgezeichnet hat, löscht das bitte, damit er zu schnell wie möglich vergessen wird, was da passiert ist. Also das war äh.
Das war.
Es war wirklich der Tiefpunkt. Ich bin ähm ich meine, für mich war dieses Camp, ich war.
Auch dort ein ähm.
Also ich habe da im Rahmen meines Jobs auch äh Workshops gemacht und ähm war also nicht nicht nur freizeitlich da. Ähm.
Ich aber für mich war dieses Camp echt einfach,
eine herbe Enttäuschung. Also es war echt einfach eine eine herbe Enttäuschung, dieses dieses Feeling ist einfach nicht aufgekommen. Ähm ich habe.
Ernsthaft gedacht so jetzt in Anbetracht dieser ganzen NSA Sache und so. Wenn das jetzt das ist, was wir als
als internationale äh Hackerszene irgendwie im Sommer hinkriegen, dieses Sponsoren, getränkte Dinge mit diesen weißen.
Hast wahrscheinlich die die Closing-Keynote von Ellenor verpasst, oder?
Genau, das wurde ja groß äh die muss ja das große Ding gewesen sein, ja, also.
Das war super, das war auch einfach, das war sozusagen, glaube ich, genau so die Zusammenfassung dessen, was so da vermisst hast und das war als, als sozusagen, äh, Schlussstatement für das Quer, war das super.
Aber das war auch jetzt nicht die Schlusskino der Veranstaltung, sondern es war.
Nee, nee, natürlich nicht vom vom Neuseestre.
Quer. Ich glaube, der der Talk ist, äh es gibt, glaube ich, sogar ein Transkript hier auf Netz.
Es haben sich direkt im Anschluss daran Leute in sozusagen in der letzten Nacht Samstag Nacht hingesetzt und haben das Ding transkribiert, weil weil das so cool war. Und es gibt.
Es gibt auch eine Aufzeichnung, also hier gibt's auch einen MP3, aber Netzpolitik org, ist das weitgehend äh zitiert und dann auch glaube ich.
Und das mal.
Auch verlinkt, weiß ich nicht ganz genau, ja genau, hier ist das Transkript.
Genau.
Also die die hat im Grunde einfach alles nochmal genau das gesagt, was dir gefehlt hat, würde ich sagen, was zumindest für die Leute, die sich da in dem Umfeld bewegt haben, ähm das gut aufgefangen haben, weil von dem Rest war ja eh nichts zu erwarten. Das war, das haben die ja sehr schön beschrieben, ähm auch auch relativ deutlich. Es war einfach das kleine Camp im großen Camp und hat das alles so ein bisschen mit
gedeckt, äh da hat nichts daran geändert, dass äh die Lage momentan schwierig ist. Da werden wir, glaube ich, ja gleich auch nochmal drauf zu sprech,
Ähm aber äh das, dass da sowas wie Haltung erforderlich ist und ähm welche Haltung das sein sollte, das hat sie da sehr deutlich gemacht.
Super, dann verlinken wir das auch nochmal. Es aber es war, ja, also ich kann's nur nochmal betonen, es war für mich einer ähm.
Sehr äh herbe Enttäuschung insgesamt, wie das da liegt. So kann es nicht weitergehen. Das ist, glaube ich, allen klar, sowohl der der Fox-IT-Fraktion als auch den guten ähm.
Wird weitergehen.
Genau und jetzt wird's halt jetzt, jetzt genau, jetzt bin ich halt gespannt, also diese Veranstaltung wird auf jeden Fall ein Wendepunkt oder hoffentlich ein Wendepunkt darstellen, noch so eine Veranstaltung wird sich, glaube ich, keiner geben. Ähm.
Man kann hoffen, also ich glaube, es gab jetzt schon erste Gerüchte, das nächste Holland-Camp macht Noise Square, weil Fox IT macht's nicht. Ähm das ist.
Das habe ich noch nicht gehört. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob die, ob die das gerne wollen.
Aber man, ich glaube, es ist allen klar, dass es so nicht weitergehen kann und man muss jetzt sehen, was äh.
Holland an der Stelle. Also ich meine, wir haben ja schon gehört, sehr viel äh dieser Probleme, ja, äh sind allein aus diesen absurden Regularien, die dort eingehalten werden müssen, herausgegangen. Also.
Mir auch beschrieben wurde, ist das sozusagen so als Erklärung für das eigene Versagen. Letztens aus holländischer Perspektiv
wir haben ja keinen CCC. Ihr habt den halt, der kann das auch finanziell
und organisatorisch leisten, das haben wir nicht, deswegen müssen wir auf die Sponsoren zurückgreifen. Ähm weiß ich nicht, ob das eins zu eins tatsächlich so stimmt, aber das fand ich auf jeden Fall eine plausible Erklärung und ich
glaube es gibt viele Leute, die ganz stark motiviert sind, jetzt sowas wie den CCC in Holland zu starten, um zu vermeiden, dass sowas wieder passiert.
Also letzteres glaube ich wird sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig. Die Idee ist ja schon ein paar Mal äh verfolgt worden. Ich kann da jetzt auch, will auch jetzt an der Stelle nicht für den Club sprechen, aber ich meine.
Gibt, dann könnte man ja auch mal auch überlegen, ob man den nicht vielleicht als Sponsor äh gewinnt an der Stelle, ja, also das.
Die beteiligten Parteien mal miteinander sprechen.
Ich verrate wahrscheinlich nicht zu viel, äh wenn ich sage, dass es die Debatte gab,
diese Fox IT-Sache aufkam. Und es gab äh also es gab natürlich wurde auch diskutiert, ob der CCC im Prinzip einfach Fox IT daraus kauft.
Der der Vorschlag kam.
Ja gut, also das sind jetzt Ausrisse, da wollen wir jetzt
mal hier gar nichts an die Wand malen da. Bis dahin vergeht auch noch viel Zeit. Es muss sich überhaupt erstmal abzeichnen, dass sich dann äh Team findet, äh was bereit ist, das in vier Jahren dann nochmal zu machen. Also bis dahin wird noch viel äh Zeit vergehen. Ich denke, jetzt konzentriert sich auch alles erstmal auf den Kongress
Und der wiederum könnte ganz schön brennen.
Das sollte er wohl. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, was du damit meinst, aber.
Na ja, also das Feuer, was äh Dinos jetzt vermisst hat, äh ich denke mal, das dürfte sich da sehr wohl äh kanalisieren können.
Und wie gesagt, also Neusi ist quer, das war einfach so dynamisch und auch,
cool im Bereich Zusammenarbeit unterschiedlicher Organisationen, Leute, die die selber äh programmieren und andere Leute, die eher versuchen, Software zu vermitteln und äh Leute, die ähm,
versuchen so was wie Userfeedback so ein bisschen zu kanalisieren und Verbindungen zu schaffen haben einfach echt super zusammengearbeitet da und war ganz klar das Bedürfnis, dass es sozusagen wie die gewissermaßen,
die physische Repräsentanz äh äh der Community, also dieser, ich weiß nicht, äh.
Liberation.
Ja eben auch so ein ganz großes Dach ist über ganz vielen verschiedenen Leuten und Organisationen, die eben auch wieder,
programmieren für den guten Zweck in gewisser Maßen betreiben und ähm dass das mal so ein bisschen noch außerhalb dieser einen Mailingliste stattfinden zu lassen und zu vernetzen
war offensichtlich ein starkes Bedürfnis, dass es irgendwas jenseits von dieser Mailing-Liste als als
ähm Netzwerk gibt und dass es das weitergeben sollte, also bis hin zu Träumen, sowas bei der South by Southwelsen zu wiederholen, wo ich äh und
gedacht haben, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert, aber ähm sofort die Frage entstand, machen wir gewissermaßen als Zusammenhang weiter
bin ziemlich sicher, dass es ein Essen, wie beim Kongress geben wird und und inwieweit sich das sonst manifestieren kann beim Kongress, äh ist im Moment unklar, weil wiederum auch der
konstituierende Moment des Widerstandes gegen die Umorga, der fehlt ja dann. Und was was kann das eigentlich sein? Ähm aber also,
denke, dass ähm das Bedürfnis da ist, so was weiter zu haben und auszubauen und das es das geben wird.
Interessant ist glaube ich für für die Amerikanischen äh Campbesucher äh muss das ja trotzdem noch eine total krasse Sache gewesen sein, weil sowas wie wie so ein oder überhaupt so ein Camp, haben die ja trotzdem nicht, ne? Also in äh Film.
Leider auch mittlerweile gibt es ja auch in den USA äh ähnliche Unternehmungen. Turcamp und äh.
Ja. Okay.
Andere, die haben, die waren jetzt auch alle ausreichend oft äh auf den europäischen Veranstaltungen, dass da schon der Wunsch.
Um mehr mal zu sehen, wie man das.
Das auch zu machen, genau. Ne.
Okay, also gemischte Gefühle auf meiner Seite nach diesem Camp. Äh ich blicke nach vorne, weil es kann nur besser werden. Neusis wäre auf jeden Fall ein ähm.
Eine sehr positive Sache, die da stattgefunden hat,
hoffen wir, dass da jetzt nochmal mehr, dass die Leute, die sich da jetzt gefunden haben, noch mehr äh und enger zusammenarbeiten.
Genau, mal gucken. Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Haben wir lange übers Camp geredet. Ah, ich glaube, das, wie gesagt, das wird irgendwie in die Geschichte eingehen, als äh hoffentlich als Tiefpunkt, nicht als Anfang. Anfang des Untergangs. Ähm.
Wenn wir uns wieder den den Geschehnissen in der Welt zu äh AdWords Snowden hat jetzt ein,
temporäres Asyl in Russland bekommen, für ein Jahr. Ähm er darf sich also in Russland jetzt frei bewegen
Und dann wird irgendwann über den äh Rest entschieden, ob er jetzt also ein dauerhaftes Asyl da bekommt oder so. Und ähm die Reaktion der USA war also sehr äh angepisst,
Und zwar ähm sagte Obama dann.
Dass er äh Putin nicht am Rande des G20-Treffens
treffen möchte, welches eben am September in Sankt Petersburg stattfindet und statt da ein paar Tage vorher anzureisen und mit
Putin zu reden, hat sich Obama entschlossen, stattdessen nach Schweden zu fliegen und äh sich dort mit den
der Regierung oder was zu unterhalten und die offizielle Begründung ist also ein ein diplomatisches äh,
Da sieht man wieder, wie diplomatische Sprache funktioniert. Die haben also gesagt, die USA, das Weiße Haus hat Verlautbaren lassen in Anbetracht des mangelnden Vorankommens in den Themenfeldern der Raketenabwehr, der Handelsbeziehungen, der
globalen Sicherheit und der Menschenrechte in den letzten zwölf Monaten halten wir es für konstruktiver,
das Treffen zu verschieben, bis wir mehr Ergebnisse auf der gemeinsamen Agenda haben. Das ist also die Begründung der USA.
Dass äh Obama äh sich nicht mit Putin treffen möchte, weil wir haben ja nix zu besprechen. Es ist ja nichts passiert. Ähm Russland sagt ähm
Ja, es äh hat offensichtlich ja mit Snowden zu tun und ähm sie bedauern, dass äh die USA weiterhin
nicht bereit sind für eine Begegnung auf Augenhöhe beziehungsweise in Deutschland wurde das von den Medien übersetzt für eine,
gleichberechtigte Beziehung, also ähm es ist schon sehr, ich finde das schon sehr, sehr.
Sehr, sehr äh krass, was äh wie sich die US-Regierung oder wie sich insbesondere Obama da jetzt verhält, ja, also.
Ja, die er ist auf jeden Fall gut dabei, seine Vorschusslorbeeren komplett aufzuessen. Also bei mir ist er jetzt schon durch.
Ich meine, er hat schon vorher nicht in allen Punkten so eine super gute.
Nee, aber äh irgendwie war man immer noch so ein bisschen bereit, äh äh da ans Gute äh zu denken, aber die Nummer ist äh geht einfach gar nicht mehr.
Na mein Eindruck ist die USA fassen sich einfach gerade in dem, was sie darstellen,
wirklich jetzt vollständig selber auf. Also jede Reste von Demokratie und Rechtsstaat oder Freiheit oder so, da kannst du nur noch in Gelächter ausbrechen, wenn du dir anguckst, was da abläuft, wie die mit Whistleblowern umgehen, wie sie mit dieser Snowden-Geschichte umgehen,
Urteil sowieso. Ähm und das wird ja auch sozusagen,
zunehmend von von gar nicht unwichtigen äh Amerikanern selber auch gesagt, dass ähm weiß ich nicht, wer war das Daniel Elspberg, der gesagt hat, oft die Kritik, warum Snowden nicht in den USA geblieben ist. Ähm so wie er selber auch, der sich dem
ausgesetzt hat, also der Whistleblower, der, der im Grunde den Vietnam-Krieg äh beendet hat, wenn man, wenn man mal so will ähm und die Pentagon Papers geleakt hat und hat halt auch gesagt, ja, als als ich das gemacht habe, da hatten wir noch sowas wie einen Rechtsstaat und Meinungsfreiheit und ich konnte auch
im laufenden Verfahren mich öffentlich dazu äußern. Snowden mit Snowden würde so umgegangen werden wie mit Manning, der würde sofort weggesperrt werden, er hätte überhaupt keine Möglichkeit und ich kann ihm nichts anderes raten, als um Gottes Willen nicht in die USA zurückzukehren.
Jimmy Kater hat sich da ja recht äh unzweideutig äh geäußert und meinte die amerikanische, also aus seiner Sicht und man muss dazu sagen, Mikata ist derjenige, der mittlerweile so Wahl äh Beobachtung macht international, ja.
Jimmy Carter, der Ex-US-Präsident.
Der Ex-US-Präsident meinte wörtlich, dass die amerikanische äh Regierung derzeit äh nichts die Anforderungen an demokratischen Prinzipien erfüllen würde.
Sagt Jimmy.
Der Ex-Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten, der.
Allem, was für einer, ja?
Also.
So eine Zitate kannst du, das ist natürlich wirklich ein sehr schönes Loch mit der Figur, aber also jede Menge und auch von von anderen bekannten Figuren finden und es ist ja auch einfach total offensichtlich, also.
Ist völlig, völlig fertig, ist da stattfindet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr jetzt gleich zu Michael Hayden übergehen willst, aber das würde da, finde ich, sehr gut rein. Also diese diese Reaktion dazu
erstens jetzt so mit Russland umzugehen, wo, ich weiß gar nicht, wer das jetzt kürzlich geschrieben hat, die Russen, die lachen sich doch jetzt gerade halb,
ja, also diese diese das ist war mal der kalte Krieg, wo Russland äh und die Sowjetunion, der Inbegriff der Überwachung und und des Stasi-Staats gewesen sind KGB und was nicht und Putin sowieso der lupenreinen Demokrat,
ähm
wären die USA immer noch, ähm weiß ich nicht, Hillary Clinton, die irgendwie reden über das freie Internet hält und so weiter und und versucht, sich selber als als weiterhin Vorreiter von Demokratie und Freiheit international zu verkaufen, ähm äh.
Muss man jetzt nicht weiter kommentieren, was das bedeutet, aber sozusagen dieses Image immer noch verkörpert hat. Und jetzt ähm haben sie ein Whistleblower,
der der im Bereich Überwachung Sachen liegt und sich dann nach Russland flüchten muss und von denen geschützt wird, das ist so, da kannst du eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur lachend aufm Fußboden liegen, weil wie sich Historie da gerade entwickelt
wickelt und dann diese Reaktion der US-Regierung, die weiterhin die ganze Zeit sagt, das ist alles richtig, die müssen alle eingeknastet werden und die Hacker und so sind jetzt die neuen Terroristen äh.
Spannend ist eigentlich auch, dass sich inzwischen so die diese Stimmen leiser werden, die äh Snowdens Wahl nach äh Russland geflohen zu sein, äh kritisieren, ne. Also ich.
Ich würde in seinem eigenen Interesse immer noch denken, das ist bestimmt nicht die optimale Situation für ihn da, weil,
Putin ihn da jetzt nicht einfach nur schützen will, sondern natürlich für irgendwas benutzen, solange wir ihm nützlich ist, ihn vielleicht schützt und was dann passiert, halte ich für sehr unsicher und unklar.
Glaube allerdings, dass auch kaum ein anderes Land als eine Großmacht in Anführungszeichen, in der Lage ist, ihm äh wirklich Schutz zu bieten.
In dem Moment würde ich dann gerne vielleicht nochmal kurz die deutsche Regierung und die ist total versagen in dem Bereich
erwähnen wollen, also und sämtliche Leute, die sagen, unsere Gesetze geben das nicht her, dass er als politischer Flüchtling anerkannt wird, das können wir hier gerade nicht so machen, also,
lautet lautes Gelächter gleich hinterher, ja
wenn's eine politische Entscheidung gibt, jemanden aufnehmen zu wollen, die kann man einfach fällen und sagen, der wird aufgenommen. Äh äh dafür gibt es zig Beispiele in der Geschichte und dazu braucht es nicht fehlen. Selbstverständlich wäre das möglich gewesen und genau die richtige Entscheidung und auch da einfach nichts zu sagen und sich so
können hier leider nichts machen, die Bürokratie und die Gesetze und also finde ich echt ein totales Skandal, albern, versagen, ja.
Das nicht machen, aber ne? Es ist natürlich einfach ist einfach nur Angst, ja.
Ja Angst und irgendwie warum auch, äh also das gesamte Verhalten der deutschen Regierung bezogen auf NSA und BND und so weiter. Dieses Stillhalten, ich sage nichts, ich weiß von nichts, ich kann mir das alles nicht erklären und wir können da auch überhaupt gar nichts machen,
ähm ich glaube, sie hat versucht, still zu halten bis zur Wahl, der Hoffnung, dass das weiter gut geht wie bisher. Ähm was ja auch erstaunlich gut gegangen ist, was ich nicht so richtig.
Ich glaube auch gar nicht mal, dass das jetzt nur die Regierung ist,
Ich glaube, das ist einfach mal an der Stelle auch wirklich so diese deutsche Staats äh Raison und das ist jetzt äh äh ne, mit der SPD da nicht sehr wie anders gelaufen wäre, wenn äh wir jetzt gerade eine solche Regierung gehabt hätten.
Wer war das noch gleich der Putin für den Demokraten erklärt hat?
Großes Kino, ja.
Ich komme mir doch immer, kommen wir mal zu dem, zu dem Vorankommen des äh NSA-Skandals. Ähm.
Denn wir trennen ja jetzt das äh das wir's trennen jetzt immer die die Snowden, das Snowden Panorama von denen, von dem was eigentlich geschach. Ähm,
Es in der Zeit seit der letzten Folge Lokbuch Netzpolitik wurde bekannt, dass irgendwie von der NSA einhundert Millionen Pfund an den äh GCAQ gegangen sind zum Ausbau von äh ähm
Programm zur Informationsbeschaffung. Wir wissen GCHQ ähm der britische Geheimdienst, der äh
Europas Internet überwacht, ja? Ähm da sind also einmal sechsundzwanzig Millionen Euro ungefähr für
geflossen von USA dorthin dreiundzwanzigeinhalb Millionen für irgendeine Abhörstation in einer Kleinstadt beaut,
Glaube ich, heißt die, äh wo irgendwie ein ähm unter ein Untersehkabel terminiert, ja. Ähm was ich spannend finde, ist,
Wer ist da jetzt eigentlich, wessen äh bitch? Ja, also ich meine, der ähm,
lassen sich die ähm lassen sich die lassen sich der britische Geheimdienst, seine Infrastruktur einfach von den Amis finanzieren,
oder kaufen die Amis von den Briten Informationen, die sie selber nicht äh beschaffen dürfen. Wir wissen ja, die NSA darf nicht gegen Amerikaner spionieren,
darf das? Ja, wie ist da die Kooperation? Also ist ja ist äh verdichten sich ja die Hinweise, dass genau so die Kooperationen ab.
D liefert Daten, ja?
Ja, BND liefert irgendwelche Daten, also man fragt sich, was sie da überhaupt machen. Ähm so viel also interessant.
In dem Kontext fand ich ja wirklich interessant, das habe ich irgendwann in Kempten nebenbei gesehen, dass die Bundesanwaltschaft ein Verfahren wegen Spionage erwägt und sich darüber mit dem Verfassungsschutz in dem BND unterhält, wo ich dachte, das das klingt,
so gut, das kann gar nicht wahr sein, aber das finde ich auf jeden Fall interessant.
Spionageermittlung.
Spionage gegen gegen, also Spionage, Ermittlung wegen Spionage zulasten des der deutschen Bevölkerung.
Das stand da nicht drin, unbekannt, aber sie unterhalten sich mit dem BND und dem Verfassungsschutz und wer würde denn sozusagen die Daten übermitteln, unberechtigter Weise, also das finde ich.
Finde ich interessant. Ja, ungewöhnlich auch, passt nicht so richtig in die Linie.
In den USA finden Ermittlungen statt übrigens und zwar der US Investigation Services, ist eine ein Unternehmen, das
die Überprüfung von Regierungsangestellten und Bewerbern durchführt für ihre Security Clyance. Und man ermittelt jetzt gegen die, dass sie ihren Job nicht
ordentlich gemacht haben, weil schließlich ist der Snowden ja äh bei ihnen durch das äh Screening Verfahren gegangen und jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, äh.
Die sollten auch alle festgenommen werden.
Ob man denen nicht dafür, ob man die nicht haftbar machen kann, dass sie da so ein äh Verbrecher äh reingelassen haben, ja? Also offensichtlich haben die ihre Arbeit nicht gemacht. Also auch in den USA ist man äh zieht man jetzt juristische Konsequenzen aus der Angelegenheit.
Du wolltest noch was sagen, Tim, Entschuldigung.
Äh ja, na ja, also diese ganze äh,
das Gefühl alle die einzige Limitierung die diese Geheimdienste überhaupt noch zu besitzen scheinen und wo sie sich zumindest noch so halbwegs im Kopf drum rum machen ist dieses man spioniert nicht die eigenen Leute aus,
ja? Alles andere scheißegal.
In dem Kontext habe ich gestern das interessanteste in der Berliner Zeitung gelesen, wo nämlich das erste Mal soweit ich das beobachten kann, in einem Bericht über den NSU-Prozess erwähnt wurde, dass es da eine DVD mit ähm NSA,
also NSA äh äh Daten gegeben haben soll, die geholfen hat gegen Nazis. Also da gibt es offensichtlich irgendwelche also das ist,
interessant. NSU, NSA.
Ja, also wie schnell man von der einen Organisation zur anderen kommt, das haben wir damals beim blinkenden schon äh sehr schön mit unserem TLA Animationen gezeigt. Aber ich wollte auf was anderes hinaus, nämlich ähm.
Also jeder, jeder darf alles, nur die eigenen Leute nicht, aber wenn man sich halt international zusammentut und sich dann gegenseitig die Datensätze äh äh zuschiebt, so, dann äh hat man die Daten dann halt trotzdem,
Ja, was kann denn die NSA dafür, wenn der BND ihn auf einmal äh die abgehörten Amerikaner frei Haus liefert?
Das ist ja alles nur Kooperation. Ja, so hoppala und äh ist sicherlich nicht davon aus, also man könnte vielleicht sogar davon ausgehen, dass natürlich der BND entsprechende Daten dann auch erhält. So nach dem Motto, wir haben die Deutschen ja gar nicht über äh überwacht. Das waren ja die Amerikaner,
Ja
Den haben wir einen Hinweis bekommen.
Ja, was äh ja, das lag dann bei uns so im Briefkasten, kann man ja nichts äh dafür. Also es ist auf jeden Fall alles ganz schön äh fishi und diese Zahlung, ja.
Mir so als erstes auch so dieses Gefühl, meine Herren, das ist ja auch schon so richtig ein Business. Also dieses ganze,
Geheimdienstdaten austauschen, dass es auf einmal richtig Geld wert und äh natürlich, wenn du in dem Moment, äh wenn du so gute Leistungen erzielst, dass sogar die Amerikaner dann anfangen, für irgendwas zu bezahlen, so, dann ist das ja richtiger InCup.
Auch wenn jetzt diese hundert Millionen Pfund vielleicht so viel nun auch erstmal wieder nicht sind, ne? Das ist äh eigentlich Pipifax äh auf dem Level und wenn ich's richtig gelesen habe, aber wer weiß das schon so ganz genau, war das ja für den Bau eines Gebäudes, ne? Also von daher wahrscheinlich auch,
ja ja Geld ist Geld.
Zusammenarbeit gibt's ja nicht nur zwischen dann den Diensten äh überhaupt, sondern was ja dann auch noch irgendwie äh durchgeisterte wandern, dass sich Hinweise verdichteten, dass die,
Geheimdienste der die Polizeitätigkeit unterstützen in den USA. Das also muss ja auch naheliegend, ne? Wenn ich mit dem Geheimdienst, der äh nicht den den Rechts nicht,
Also wie wie war's nochmal? Legalitätsprinzip wäre so das Opportunitätsprinzip. Der Geheimdienst hört einfach so vor sich hin ab. Äh Polizei muss aber irgendwie darf ja nicht gerichtlich verwertbare Beweise nicht gerichtlich verwerten. Und ähm jetzt könnte,
ist ja so der Fall denkbar, dass der Geheimdienst der Bundespolizei ähm in den USA so einen Hinweis gibt und sagt, guckt, schaut euch doch mal das und das an.
Das ist aber hier auch so.
Und dann muss sich der muss sich die Polizei, weil sie ja alles sieht, quasi eine Beweiskette konstruieren, um irgendwie zu Eck oder eine Ermittlungskette konstruieren, um zu,
irgendwie glaubhaft zu behaupten, wie sie an diese Informationen selber gekommen sind.
Obwohl sie nicht so drangekommen.
Obwohl sie das nicht dürfen, also quasi.
Wie gesagt, hier exakt genauso. Ja, also also das auch dokumentierter Maßen, das kann man wenn man so eine Terrorprozesse mal beobachtet, dann kann man das also es wird auch gesagt.
Und das ist aber, das ist doch eines der ähm also in in Deutschland nicht ganz so wichtig wie in den, also in Deutschland wird er ja sowieso gerne drüber hinweg gesehen, ne. In den USA ist es ja wirklich so.
Sowieso, also ich meine, wer beobachtet denn solche Prozesse im Detail, außer da sind jetzt irgendwie fiese Terroristen gefunden worden und ein Glück und zum Glück werden sie jetzt auch verurteilt. Also, aber die Details, das machen ja nur.
Interessiert dann keinen. Aber in den US, also wenn ich das,
sitzt einige Zeit her, dass ich das gelesen habe. Wenn ich das richtig erinnere, ist es in den USA sehr stark so, dass wenn da bestimmte Verfahrensvorgaben nicht eingehalten werden, also ein nicht legal erlangtes Beweisstück
ist einfach vor Gericht wertlos Punkt. Während in Deutschland man sagt, na ja, du, du, du, das hättest du dir auf die Weise nicht holen sollen, aber
es ist halt ein Beweisstück und jetzt berücksichtigen wir das. Während die USA da ihre Polizei sehr viel stärker, also zumindest gesetzlich sehr viel stärker in die Zange nimmt, dass also illegal ähm.
Illegal erlangte äh Beweisstücke nicht äh in den Prozess aufgenommen werden dürfen unter keinen Umständen.
Kenn mich da nicht gut genug aus, um das tatsächlich vergleichen zu können, aber
das ist ja sowieso die reine Theorie, also wir haben ja theoretisch auch einen verfassungsmäßigen Grundsatz, der eine Trennung von Polizei und Geheimdiensten ähm äh und und so was wie eine Bundespolizei aus bestimmten Gründen nicht haben will, was was kein Mensch mehr ernst nimmt.
Und die Zusammenarbeit findet statt und ähm also ich es gibt leider nicht viele von diesen Prozessen, wo es tatsächlich dann auch ausführliche Berichte gibt und noch weniger Leute gibt, es die sich
tatsächlich also so eine Berichte dann durchlesen, aber da findest du Absurditäten auf einer Skala, da da kannst du dir die Haare ausreißen, was in solchen Prozessen faktisch stattfindet und wieder, wer mit wem umgeht, das ist
alles total lächerlich und und nicht so, wie man sich das normalerweise vorstellt, wenn man das irgendwann mal im äh Politikunterricht gelernt hat.
Wie so ein Rechtsstaat funktioniert, ja? Ähm,
Gibt's eigentlich zu dem Michael Hayden noch mehr zu sagen, als dass er sagt, das sind alles nie Listen, Anarchisten, Aktivisten, enormes und
Twents, die seit fünf oder sechs Jahren nicht mit dem anderen Geschlecht gesprochen haben. Ich möchte da nur darauf hinweisen, der Mann war von neunundneunzig bis zweitausendfünf NSA-Direktor und wenn das jemand weiß,
Wer wann mit welchem Geschlecht Kontakt hatte, dann ist er das. Insofern finde ich das echt mal eine interessante Feststellung, ja. Also das war ja eigentlich immer nur ein Vorurteil.
Twents ist ja auch mal geiles Schimpfwort. Du Twen. Ihr seid ja alle Twins.
Also hat der sonst noch irgendwas von, hat der sonst noch irgendwas von sich gegeben, was der Erwähnung, was Erwähnung wert ist? Nee, ne.
Nee, ich kann jetzt auch nur dieses Zitat, ich habe von dem vorher noch nicht, ich beschäftige mich normalerweise mit dem NSA-Direktor.
Jahrelanges Vorurteil über über Hacker und Nerds äh NSA.
Aber was was für eine.
Finde, dass das das ist natürlich total komisch und auch ähm kann kann man viel drüber lachen, aber die Tatsache, dass in den USA in sozusagen zunehmend gegen gegen Hacker ähm auf
verschiedensten Ebene im Moment juristisch vorgegangen wird und dass sie echt hart zuschlagen und das offensichtlich ausdehnen wollen, dass äh ist ja unübersehbar. Das.
Dass ja auch nichts Neues. Ich meine.
Und und auch nichts Neues und ähm also das finde ich tatsächlich sozusagen, wenn das so in dieser Form angesagt wird, durchaus ein bisschen beunruhigend.
Diese diese überhaupt diese Sexualisierung oder überhaupt diese diese Ebene mich erinnert das irgendwie,
wer Lust ja, wo er wegen seinen minder äh jährigen äh Prostituierten da sagt, na und ich stehe halt auf auf junge Frauen, ist immer noch besser, als wenn ich schwul wäre. Ja, also was das für eine also überhaupt.
Finde nicht die Sexualisierung, das Problem, ich finde das Problem, dass er sozusagen so in so einem Rundumschlag einfach klarmacht, die die sind nichts, ja, die sind total lächerlich, die muss man nicht ernst nehmen, das sind irgendwie die machen wir jetzt fertig.
Aber genau auf der, aber dann eignet man noch auf diesem Niveau, also auf diesen, ja, auf diesen also das finde ich ganz, ganz mager, ganz, ganz schwacher Auftritt, aber wahrscheinlich hat er viele Lacher dafür bekommen. Ich.
Ja, auf dem Level spielt sich das halt einfach ab. Ja, ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht, man, man könnte versuchen, dem Ganzen jetzt auch was positives abzugewinnen und sagen, sie rudern jetzt aber auch wirklich schon auf der niedrigsten äh Stufe und scheinen ja offensichtlich auch schwer in Panik zu sein.
Also ähm die machen da zwar jetzt den starken, ja, aber wer macht denn den starken Max? Das sind immer.
Sowas aber auch eine eine Reaktion darauf, dass dann plötzlich so so eine Konferenz für die, ich glaube, die Defcon war's, die gesagt hat, die NSA darf jetzt nicht mehr, oder? Ähm also dass da sozusagen plötzlich auch Sachen in den USA passieren, die jetzt auch nicht überzubewerten sind, aber,
wo deutlich ist, diese politische Auseinandersetzung findet statt. Und und da da wird gerangelt und die Kräfteverhältnisse sind unklar.
Na ja ähm auf der Blackhead ist ja dann der aktuelle ähm NSA-Direktor aufgetreten.
Will jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass das die Hacker gleich demnächst in den USA die die Macht übernehmen.
Ja gut, aber die Blackhead ist auch bewusst eine ganz andere Veranstaltung, auch wenn sie mal aus dem selben Umfeld heraus gegründet äh äh.
Ja, die Blackhead ist die Veranstaltung, also da da war, da saß wahrscheinlich kaum meine Publikum, dessen Firma nicht ein Vertrag mit mit der NSA hat, ja, insofern ähm hat er da.
Dass der Chef auch mal vorbeikommt.
Ja, genauso. Ey, äh haltet mal die. Übrigens, spannende Sache, da hat.
Die die neue netzpolitische irgendwie Number one in in Deutschland spielen. Online hat ja auch irgendwie gesagt, das ist applaudiert worden nach der Rede und es gab kein großartigen.
Es gab übrigens, wurde mir von jemandem erzählt, der diese Rede besucht hat, also der dort war. Ähm es hat jemand Eier und Tomaten quasi rumgereicht
in dieser Veranstaltung, also NSR-Direktor steht da, erzählt was auf der Blackhead und ähm jemand, der auch bekannt ist, hat dann äh,
Eier durch die Publikumsreihen gereicht, ja? Und äh die wurden.
Daraufhin wegen Terrorismus fest.
Nö, die sind einfach weitergereicht worden, die hat keiner genommen.
Das finde ich ja natürlich irgendwie schade sozusagen. Ja, also finde ich einen netten, finde ich, finde ich fast schon mutig, muss ich sagen, weil.
Endet am Ende der Stuhlreihe dann von den Securitys eingesammelt, ne? Aber es hat äh keiner, also es die sind halt ihre Reihe durchgegangen, ja und keiner hat also ich weiß nicht,
Also gut getreut so finde ich super, das einfach mal gesehen zu haben, so da hat er viele Leute in diese Situation gebracht so und die haben halt in der Situation das Ei nicht genommen und weitergereicht. Da müssen sie, damit müssen sie leben, das müssen sie so erzählen.
Als ich damals bei der Blackhead äh als dem NSA-Direktor applaudiert wurde, habe ich die Schale Eier weitergereicht.
Übrigens hier dein Michael Hayden, von dem du äh gerne so viel gewusst haben möchtest.
Ja. Ich wusste gar nicht wie.
Äh Wikipedia hat er äh verschiedene Auszeichnungen erhalten, so allerlei amerikanisches Zeug, aber als letztes auch das große Verdienstkreuz des Verdienstordens der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Ach herrje.
Überraschung, aber auch äh äh ich verweise übrigens, was ich auch gestern im Radio gehört habe, Deutschlandfunk ein sehr
cooles Interview mit einer amerikanischen Politikwissenschaftler, wo sehr ausführlich darüber gesprochen wird, über das deutsch-amerikanische Verhältnis und dem sozusagen relativ intensiv nachgefragt,
ob das denn jetzt rechtmäßig ist, wenn die Deutschen ausspioniert werden und die Zusammenarbeit mit dem BND
der im Grunde die ganze Zeit sagt, das ist uns irgendwie total scheißegal. Wir machen, was wir wollen und das ist auch ganz normal und das muss Amerika auch machen, also nichts, wo man jetzt sagen würde, das ist echt eine eine totale Revolution, das ist nichts, was der hat nichts Neues gesagt, aber der hat nochmal sehr deutlich und klar gesagt.
In welchem Programm war das, was.
Deutschlandfunk.
Welchem Segment.
Ähm das war ungefähr um vierzehn Uhr. Da gibt's so eine Sendung. Ähm ich ich suche das euch auch gleich nochmal raus. Ähm äh,
da kann man sich auch nochmal anhören und durchlesen mit Trans-Transkript und auch im Verhältnis sozusagen kommt auch Snowden drin vor, das Verhältnis zu Russland und ähm,
ich fand das, ich
Auto gefahren und hab mir das so nebenbei im Radio angehört und hörte den also sprechen der irgendwie die ganze Zeit sagt das ist uns irgendwie das ist wenn ihr das nicht rechtmäßig findet und irgendwie ja ist das denn
Ist das denn Frage nochmal? Ähm aber die Deutsch-amerikanischen Beziehungen und die sind doch eigentlich freundschaftlich und eigentlich macht man das doch nicht und ja, aber wenn das für die Interessen der USA wichtig ist, dann machen wir das natürlich,
die ganze Zeit fand ich schon nochmal gut.
Ähm es ist etwas passiert, was ich, glaube ich, in der, in der ersten Folge, in der wir diese Snowden-Sache behandelt haben, schon vorhergesagt habe. Rüssler,
Philipp Rößler geht hin und sagt, wir brauchen ergänzend auch eigenständige deutsche und europäische Lösungen und Angebote in der IT-Infrastruktur. Ja, also jetzt geht die äh man will natürlich jetzt auch wirtschaftlich auf dieser Panikwelle
reiten, die also äh amerikanische Diensteanbieter betrifft, gleichzeitig kommt der Bitcom,
Branchenverband der IT-Unternehmen äh und sagt, wir wollen einen IT Security-TÜV, am liebsten soll der natürlich am BSI angesiedelt sein.
BSI hatte ich ja hier schon öfter mal äh kritisiert, als äh Wirtschaftsförderungsinstitutionen im Bereich der IT und IT Security. Ähm.
Sie sagen also ja äh es wäre halt ganz schön, wenn wir irgendwie so einen Security-TÜV-Siegel hätten, ja? Und das das BSI macht ja genau das, die machen ja nicht, nicht viel mehr als irgendwelche Standards und Spezifikationen schreiben.
Wo man dann nachher sagen kann, wir folgen äh wir haben das äh BSI-Siegel. Ich hatte hier schon, ich glaube, ist ungefähr ein Jahr hier her hier schon darüber gesprochen, dass das BSI an einem,
äh oder einer Zertifizierung für Secure-Cloud-Dienste in Deutschland arbeitet, um irgendwie dieser äh diese,
diesen äh Hintertreffen äh entgegenzuwirken, in das die deutschen Anbieter äh in Cloud-Bereich geraten sind. Ähm.
Gleichzeitig sagt der Bitcom, ja also im Bereich der Hardware, also was Router und sowas angeht,
ist unser Vorsprung äh ist der Vorsprung von USA und China nicht mehr aufzuholen. Aber was die Cloud angeht, da können wir doch jetzt nochmal richtig punkten. Also dieses Cloud-Paper, was ich da schon vor
vom vor weiß ich nicht wie viel Monaten mal kritisiert habe wird da jetzt relativ bald nochmal rausgeholt werden und man kann sich da also nur an den Kopf fassen
wenn man sich überlegt, was das BSI hier zum Beispiel mit D Mail für einen äh für einen Quatsch zertifiziert hat, der nämlich genau auch darauf ausgelegt ist von
den deutschen Diensten eben abgegriffen werden zu können, ja? Also aber das war vorherzusehen. Ich war so ein bisschen verwundert, dass das jetzt erst passiert ist.
Wir hatten's gerade schon erwähnt, der BND filtert E-Mails ähm von DE Domains und Telefon.
Mal kurz zu dieser ganzen Cloud äh Sache, die Wasser auch sehr schön rein äh fällt, ist ja, dass jetzt auch äh USA sich so ein wenig regt und die
nicht ganz genau aus welcher Organisation heraus das kam, aber so mehrere Cloud-Anbieter dann so mal eine Einschätzung gemacht haben, dass dieser ganze Skandal sie in den nächsten Jahren so zwischen fünfzig und achtzig Milliarden Dollar äh
Verluste,
wird so, also das ist jetzt auch mal sehr interessant für mich zu sehen, was sich im Valley so tut, weil die sind da nicht gerade besonders im ja, ein äh,
ein System, ich meine dieses ganze moderne Internet, was für heute als selbstverständlich nehmen, ja? Kann man sagen, ist einfach mal zu zu neunzig Prozent
da entstanden so. Das ist einfach der Thinking, da sind einfach die interessanten äh Projekte und alle Dienste, die wir heute äh als selbstverständlich benutzen,
kommen von da. Ja, man kann jetzt sogar Microsoften zunehmendem Maße ausschließen,
also ist gut, da sind vielleicht dann die anderen fünf bis zehn Prozent. So und die sind einfach beunruhigt.
Also ich kann jetzt nicht für jeden sprechen. Er mag's auch äh unverbesserliche äh Staatsfreunde äh und Patrioten geben, die der Meinung sind, das müsste müsste alles so sein, trotz alledem
Das geht jetzt einfach mal schwer in ihr Business, weil die ursprüngliche Aussage mit hier das freie Netz freie Ideen lala, ja, was weiß ich, was sie auch noch für Recruiting-Probleme äh dadurch
kommen werden in der in der Zukunft, weil einfach die USA natürlich auch als Land dadurch ähm wieder etwas aktiver geworden ist. Also so.
So einer relativ weit breit äh zitierten Erklärung äh die Empfehlung gewesen, überhaupt keine US-Services mehr zu benutzen, ne? Haben wir noch.
Kommen wir gleich zu, kommen wir gleich zu, kommen wir gleich zu ähm wir müssen ja auch so ein bisschen äh.
Ich wollte nur einfach sagen, dass das hört man ja sozusagen zunehmend und viel und das wird noch mehr sein und das hat natürlich ähm auch
Folgen ganz unterschiedlicher Art und Weise. Wenn jetzt ich weiß nicht, ich war bin letzte Woche befragt worden von Fokus Money zu irgendwie Tipps im Bereich Sicherheit und
und auch da ist sozusagen eine ausführliche Anleitung zu E-Mails, verschlüsseln und all sowas und möglichst keine Uhr. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob die das explizit sagen, aber wo ich auch gedacht habe, das nimmt erstaunliche Formen an hier.
Stimmt.
Also Zeit berichtete dann der BND-Filter, E-Mails mit äh von DE Domans und Telefonate mit der Vorwahl äh plus neunundvierzig, um keine Deutschen zu überwachen. Das ist natürlich ähm,
Also da kann man nur sagen, ist das jetzt äh Inkompetenz, Fahrlässigkeit oder Lüge?
Ja, also erst kann mir ja nicht vorstellen, aber es zeigt genau, dass nämlich dieses G zehn Gesetz, in dem das ja gesagt wird, so und dann das gleiche Problem haben die Amerikaner ja auch mit ihren Geheimdiensten.
G zehn Gesetz gesagt, dass man nur Änderungen DE.
Nee, nee, dass sie, dass sie, dass der BND nicht Inland spionieren darf,
So ist ein Auslandsgeheimnis, ne? Idee davon, eine Idee eines Auslandsgeheimdienstes. So und natürlich ist diese diese Vorgabe des G zehn Gesetzes in einem Internet,
nur schwer äh umzusetzen. Das ist ja genau das Problem des Internets, dass äh man irgendwie diese Nationengrenzen da irgendwie nicht mehr drin hat.
Die alle keine Adressen.
Also totaler äh also äh vermutlich eine Lüge, ähm aber wahrscheinlich die einzige, die sie.
Ehrlich gestanden, glaube ich, dass neun fünfundneunzig Prozent von allem, was dazu gerade gesagt ist, ist alles Spin, ja?
Das ist ähm da das ist irgendwie so der Versuch, irgendwie in die Lage unter Kontrolle zu halten über über Propaganda letzten Endes. Ich glaube, dass dass wir nicht wissen, was da passiert und dass sie es uns auch nicht sagen im Moment fertig.
Schrieb ja dann ja Pech für die Leute, die eine GMX Punkt net Adresse haben,
ja, ja. Okay, auf jeden Fall, dann.
Na ja, ich bin im, ich bin bei Dot ORG, also das war's.
Ein Bullshit.
Dann ist jetzt endlich auch das seit Wochen erwartet, äh Steinmeier mal ins Feuer geraten, der ja früher, also wir haben das ja alles schon gesagt, äh der ähm
das Kanzleramt, Kanzleramtchef war und der hat die zweitausendzwei,
in einem Abkommen die Kooperation zwischen BND und NSA abgesegnet. Da betraf das diese Abhörstation in Bad Aibling. Dafür kriegt er jetzt Ärger von der Linken und von der CDU, sagt aber selber, na ja
die an diese Weiterleitung des BNDs an die NSA kam ja erst zweitausendsieben und als zu dem Zeitpunkt zweitausendzwei als dieses Abkommen da getroffen habe war ja noch gar nicht abzusehen welche Folgen das mal haben würde.
Wer hätte denn mit so etwas rechne.
D jetzt versucht sich da irgendwie rauszuziehen, das ist ähm, weiß ich auch nicht, da könnte man einen schönen Cartoon draus machen oder so, zur Rolle des NSE in Deutschland. Das ist doch,
mittlerweile aber auch deutlich dokumentiert. Das hatten sozusagen komplett seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg durch stattgefunden, fertig, aus. Ähm,
alle, die irgendwie in der Regierung waren, stecken da irgendwie mit drin, das ist irgendwie einem klar.
Ja jetzt im deutschen Wahlkampf ist das natürlich so eine Reise nach Jerusalem, ne. Alle, alle rennen die ganze Zeit um die Stühle herum und jeder versucht noch im letzten Moment irgendwie einen Platz zu kriegen, wo er nicht dran ist, so. Mal gucken, wer übrig bleibt.
Einerseits im Wahlkampf, der Wahlkampf äh verschärft das natürlich noch so ein bisschen, aber insgesamt äh denke ich, wie das
Thema in Deutschland behandelt wird zwischen diesen Parteien. Das zeigt einfach auf so vielen Ebenen auch die Unzulänglichkeiten der parlamentarischen Demokratie, zumindest solange es irgendwie mit dem Parteiensystem verbunden ist,
überhaupt hier Alternativen zu bieten, ja? Und es ist ganz offensichtlich, dass keiner, der, der dort vertretenen Parteien irgendwie anders gehandelt hätte, ja? Es mag sein, dass die Linkspartei.
Da vielleicht noch irgendwie wäre sie an der Regierung gewesen äh da vielleicht noch irgendwie anders gehandelt hätte. Ja, aber äh auch den für die würde ich da nicht die Hand ins Feuer legen. Ähm.
Es, ich glaube, wir haben das ausreichend thematisiert.
Glaube, der Skandal dabei ist, dass dass alle weiter das Spiel mitspielen und die machen jetzt so ein bisschen Wahlkampf sagen, wer war's? Du warst, ich war's, ich war's nicht und irgendwie was war denn eigentlich in so in den Details rumpfuschen, statt irgendwie zu sagen, wir haben hier einen Punkt erreicht, da geht es so nicht mehr weiter, wie das bisher war, das müssen wir jetzt mal,
eigentlich grundlegend gesagt werden, wir machen das nicht mehr mit, das müssten eigentlich Köpfe rollen, es müsste eigentlich die gesamte Regierung grade sozusagen, wenn nicht eh Wahlkampf wäre,
echt auf den Prüfstein stehen und und grundlegend sagen, wir müssen, wir müssen das beenden, wir müssen überlegen, wie das in Zukunft weitergehen kann, aber so geht das nicht weiter,
offenlegen, was eigentlich passiert ist. Das müsste eigentlich passieren und das machen sie alle nicht, sondern tun alle so, als wäre irgendwie Business as usual und wir machen weiter Wahlkampf und piksen uns so ein bisschen gegenseitig ähm mit Stecknadeln irgendwo in der Seite und und ansonsten.
Sagt aber niemand, dass also so geht das nicht.
Und das finde ich eigentlich das das Problem gerade so was die deutsche Politik dabei angeht ich finde auch ein Problem, dass ganz viele Leute,
nicht, also dass wir gerade nicht in großen Mengen auf der Straße stehen und sagen, das muss aufhören, ich hoffe sehr, dass die Freiheit Angst vielleicht so ein bisschen sowas sein kann, aber,
ähm dieses, dass das alles nur in der Zeitung stattfindet. Die Journalisten schreiben, schreiben, schreiben irgendwie, die Leute, die sich immer mit den Themen beschäftigen, die nörgeln rum und sagen, haben wir ja immer schon gesagt und jetzt ist aber auch wirklich nicht schön. Und darüber hinaus business as usual,
und ähm ja, SPD auch, genau wie alle anderen.
Nun nicht nur die Politik. Ich denke auch, dass einfach so die Bevölkerung als solche,
immer noch nicht bereit ist, sich durch diese Skandale vom Sofa äh lo.
Nicht
vorbei, der entscheiden, also was ich auch interessant finde, das ganze Thema, also angefangen mit Prison zu dem, was wir jetzt haben, ist ein Thema in den USA und das ist ein Thema in Deutschland. Alle anderen Länder beschäftigen sich damit nicht. Insofern stehen wir noch verhältnismäßig gut da und haben übrigens, finde ich, auch eine große Verantwortung, weil wir hier
bestimmte Bewegung haben und weil wir eine bestimmte Funktion haben, weil es ganz viele Leute, das habe ich auch bei der Omen ganz viel gehört, die gesagt haben, ihr müsst das jetzt reißen.
Weil bei uns findet überhaupt gar nicht da interessiert überhaupt kein Schwein dafür
sozusagen in, wenn du dich in Deutschland umguckst, genau, die machen alle nichts, aber ne, wenn ich mal einmal kurz Leni zitieren darf, ist die Deutschen eine Revolution machen beim Bahnsteigkater und so, also bis hier mal wer auf die Straße geht, das ist auch wirklich schwierig. Ähm äh
Nichtsdestotrotz müssen wir jetzt irgendwas tun.
Die Bundesletzagentur hat was getan. Die hat nämlich für heute die Netzbetreiber
zu den Abhörvorwürfen vorgeladen und es gibt nämlich im Paragraph neunundachtzig des Telekommunikationsgesetzes ein Abhörverbot. Und wen Sie jetzt eingeladen haben.
Gestrichen.
Ne, sie haben gesagt, sie wollen mal die Mobilfunk- und Festnetzbetreiber sowie die Internetknotenbetreiber ähm haben. Und spannenderweise bestreitet der Dezix ja weiterhin überhaupt irgendwelche Abhördinger da am Laufen zu haben. Und man wird jetzt mal sehen, ähm,
nach also laut Gesetz, wenn die B Netz A äh also sie berufen sich auf einen Paragraphen.
Bei diesem, bei dieser Einladung, wenn die BNE lädt, dann müssten die dahin.
Und äh der man wird jetzt mal sehen, was ausländische Anbieter da jetzt so machen, wie die sich.
Die waren aber jetzt noch nicht da, die sind nur geladen.
Das ist quasi dieses gleichzeitig jetzt mit uns. Ja, die haben das dumm gelegt und ähm.
Also da wird man mal sehen, ob da die B10A wird da wahrscheinlich auch wieder einen Fragenkatalog irgendwohin schicken. Wir äh kennen das aus der Netzneutralität. Das wird also spannend. Ähm,
Nebenbei gab's dann auch noch so ein bisschen Wissen übers FBI zu ergattern, nämlich dass sie, wenn ein Provider nicht ausreichend kooperiert mit dem FBI, dass sie dann dort installieren, also,
gehe davon aus, dass ein Porträder so ein äh Monitoring Port, wir pipen einmal alles raus und machen's selber. Äh ist, wenn also wenn die Kooperation nicht ausreicht,
Bekannt ist allerdings nur, dass es ein Unternehmen gibt, was sich dagegen wehrt, es ist nicht bekannt, ob und wie die die einsetzen, aber wie gesagt, den Portreader kriegst du erst dann, wenn du nicht ausreichend,
ohnehin freiwillig mit dem FBI kooperierst, dann bieten sie dir an, wir können da auch eine Hardware für dich installieren, kein Problem,
Ähm und außerdem äh ist wohl auch bekannt geworden, da wurde angedeutet, dass die FBI, dass das FBI seit zehn Jahren äh sich im Bereich der engagiert
Eigenen Entwicklungen und Einkäufe in dem Bereich tätigt. Auch das war ja bekannt. Wir haben da schon mal drüber gesprochen, dass es einen sehr schönen Markt gibt für.
Explodes. Ähm das heißt, das machen wir jetzt mal nur als Kurzmeldung, weil die Sendung wird gerade relativ lang. Ähm.
Wirklich.
Heute kam die schöne Meldung rein oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob's eine schöne oder schlechte Meldung ist. Die NSA will jetzt irgendwie neunzig Prozent der SIS-Admins entlassen.
Ja, weil äh offensichtlich sind die ihn zu mächtigen Positionen und den,
der Anbieter, an dem wir deren äh Gewissenskontrolle outgesourct haben, äh hat offensichtlich nicht gute Arbeit geleistet, das heißt, wir screenen jetzt einfach nochmal alle neu und feuern neunzig Prozent. Was auch immer.
Das ist aber ein interessantes, neues Feindbild, was jetzt hier am Horizont erscheint, ja? Also bisher waren's ja eigentlich immer nur die Hacker. Also, ne, also auch die projizierte äh Bedrohung kam irgendwie immer von außen,
Und natürlich gab's auch so die als solche Leute, die irgendwie was wissen. Und Systemadministratoren.
Na ja, ich meine, uns war schon immer bewusst, ja, also Deutschland,
Deutschlands Systemadministratoren gehen wahrscheinlich nicht äh alle geschlossen auf den Kongress.
Ich meine jetzt alle, ja. Aber ich glaube, der Anteil in dieser Bevölkerungsgruppe ist doch sehr hoch,
und in den letzten zwanzig, dreißig Jahren sind ja eigentlich all die, die mit dem Netz groß geworden sind und die.
Ne, sagen wir mal, da auch eine eine gewisse Verhaftung äh drin haben, also keine. Ne, nicht die Verhaftung, ähm.
Die sind jetzt so in diesen Stellen, ja? Und in gewisser Hinsicht,
da ist glaube ich auch die Piratenpartei auch schon so ein erstes Phänomen, ja, das ist auch so ein bisschen systemadministratoren zu Parteimanagern, ja? Ähm
und äh in gewisser Hinsicht nähert sich natürlich auch so eine potentielle Whistleblower Liga, extrem,
aus dem Systemadministratorenumfeld oder beziehungsweise hat das Potenzial dazu, das zu tun,
weil eben an der Stelle mittlerweile mehr Informationen zusammenkommen, als an anderen Entscheidungspositionen.
Noch nicht mal eine Entscheidungsposition. Es ist eigentlich das ist immer das Lustige, ne? Also das Thema Administratoren wissen eigentlich am meisten, also haben am meisten Zugriff, haben aber eigentlich.
Keine große Entscheidungsbefugnis, also sie mögen eine Clearens haben, ja.
Gelegentlich machen's eher dann auch einfach Dinge, ohne sozusagen das.
Ja, das ist nochmal das andere Problem, aber,
Äh ich finde das nur interessant, dass also jetzt äh Systemadministratoren quasi als neues äh Feindbild entdeckt wurden jetzt bei den Geheimdiensten und sich äh eben auch der Loyalität dieser Gruppe auf einmal nicht mehr so äh sicher sein glauben.
Ich finde der das sozusagen praktischer Aspekt von dieser Meldung auch irgendwie interessant, weil ähm wenn die jetzt neunzig Prozent ihrer Leute entlassen äh Frage, in welchem Tempo sie das machen, aber heißt das dann entweder, dass deren Arbeit nicht notwendig war oder wo kriegen sie dann die neuen.
Ja, also da stand irgendwas von, wir wir wollen das jetzt automatisieren, da frage ich mich natürlich auch ja und wer installiert diese Automatisierung? Also, ich meine, macht er das jetzt ohne Systemadministratoren? Gibt's da jetzt irgendwie eine andere eine neue Gruppe, irgendwie castet ihr euch da jetzt Models.
Eben genau. Also wir werden's wahrscheinlich nicht erfahren, aber ich finde das irgendwie.
Ich glaube, der Plan wird schiefgehen. Das ist, glaube ich, auch eher so eine Drohung.
Kommen wir mal zu der, zu der wirklich spannenden Neuigkeit. Ähm.
Ah, jetzt endlich.
Ja, endlich, äh, vor einigen, schon vor vor einiger Zeit, wurde dann kolportiert und das ist ja eine interessante Frage,
Wo hat eigentlich sein E-Mail-Konto? Ja, das ist ja echt meine das ist ja mal interessant, ja. Also ähm das ist doch mal ein Selling Point, ja, wenn äh wenn wenn AdWords Snowden dein Kunde ist, ja? Ähm,
was E-Mails angeht und er war offensichtlich bei einem Anbieter mit dem Namen Lavabit, der ähm.
Dessen äh Betreiber irgendwie das seit zehn Jahren macht und irgendwie von dem ganzen Gmail-Ding nicht so ganz angetan war, wie die mit Privatsphäre umgehen. Und gesagt hat, ey komm, ich setze mal hier einen Mailservice auf, nenne den Lavabit und betreibe den, ja?
Und das ging dann auch über und wurde gesagt, so ey, das scheint doch mal echt ein ganz cooler E-Mail-Anbieter zu sein, so AdWord Snowden äh äh drauf, so ist doch äh wunderbar. Ähm,
Natürlich ist das auch eigentlich eine Situation, die du als E-Mail-Anbieter nicht haben willst. Ähm denn, was passierte? Ähm gestern.
Tauchte dann war diese gesamte Lavabit-Seite weg und stattdessen ist dort eine Nachricht, dass der äh Betreiber sagt,
Ja, ich habe das jetzt, ich habe hier jetzt zehn Jahre Blut, Schweiß und Tränen reininvestiert und ich habe jetzt äh ich stand jetzt vor der Wahl, das zu begraben oder äh
das verrate an meinen Kunden oder ich glaube er hat das dann den amerikanischen Volk zu begehen.
Und nachdem ich äh nach langer Meditation äh bin ich zu dem Ergebnis gekommen, dass ich das hier lieber schließe,
Mit sofortiger Wirkung. Ähm ich bedaure sehr, dass ich nicht sagen kann, was
dass ich äh gezwungen bin, äh oder dass dass ich nichts sagen kann, was die Bedingungen sind, unter denen ich jetzt äh
die mir als Zwang auffälligt wurden, weshalb ich jetzt schließen muss. Ich hatte eigentlich gedacht, dass es hier äh Freedom of Speed gäbe, aber äh der Kongress hat das äh der US-Kongress hat das anders entschieden. Das heißt, ich kann nicht sagen, was die Beweggründe sind,
Dass ich jetzt diesen Dienst schließe. Ich kann nur sagen, dass ich niemandem empfehlen würde, irgendeinen Dienstanbieter in den USA zu benutzen. Ähm.
Einer physischen Verbindung zum Land, also entweder wo der Firmensitz oder die Infrastruktur äh sich in der USA befindet.
Und ich würde mich gerne juristisch gegen den ganzen Fuß hier zur Wehr setzen. Es gibt einen äh Legal Defense Fund, da könnt ihr Geld spenden.
Und da muss ich sagen.
Also das ist ja wohl mal echt schauderhaft. Ist das ist das Wort, was ich mir dazu äh gedacht habe? Das ist doch jetzt mal echt.
Creepy. Also warum war jetzt alles andere nicht? Und das ist jetzt auf einmal creepy, also.
Ja, stimmt, hast recht. Ist auch showder.
Deutlich durchgehend creepy. Ja, ja, also das äh.
Ich finde das auf jeden Fall cool, dass er dieses Statement veröffentlich,
muss ich ehrlich sagen, weil die Frage ist natürlich auch, wie viele andere sind in einer ähnlichen Situation und veröffentlichen keine Statements dazu und sagen nicht so deutlich, was sie davon halten, weil davon abgesehen, dass er wahrscheinlich, ich weiß nicht genau, ob seine Existenz da dranhängt und wie viele noch. Ähm aber es war echt eine ziemlich.
Harte Entscheidungen zu treffen hatte. Ähm und äh die Frage, die kommt natürlich jetzt
sehr viel deutlicher auf uns zu. So was heißt das, wenn wir irgendwelche Service benutzen, die Verbindung in die USA, mal auf die eine oder andere Seite und sagen die uns das dann oder nicht? Ähm,
Kann man sagen, na klar, wir wissen irgendwie inzwischen, dass ähm alles abgehört wird. Ähm das das ist eigentlich sozusagen seit dem ersten Auftritt von AdWords Snowden ja deutlich geworden. Ähm,
Ist aber trotzdem auch nochmal ein bisschen ekelhafter, wenn man das so sozusagen aus der Nahen Ansicht bekommt und ähm,
die direkte erzwungene Kooperation von von von einer Firma wie Lavabit ähm und und dann zu sagen, das machen wir aber nicht mit,
Das ist ähm finde ich ja, dass das verdeutlicht einfach das Ganze nochmal so ganz extrem, sehr viel mehr. Und ähm.
Sind ja auch nicht die einzigen geblieben, sondern kurz danach kam ja dann schon die nächste äh Company, nämlich Silent Circle,
auch gleich die Einstellung ihres äh mit Krypto äh angereicherten Maildienstes äh angekündigt haben,
ohne jetzt unmittelbar von einem solchen Druck,
berichten, aber das Ganze ist schon eher so präventiv, so nach dem Motto, wir fangen jetzt wir warten jetzt gar nicht erst, bis es kommt, weil es kommt wahrscheinlich eh so und äh ja, das ist jetzt eine ganz interessante äh Welle.
Dazu, finde ich, ist auch wichtig, sich,
immer zu zu vergegenwärtigen, dass sie halt diese Gag-Orders haben, ja, also dass dass die eben dadrüber nicht sprechen dürfen, dass das auch deswegen mutig ist von von Lavabit das sozusagen, der
tanzt auf einem echt dünnen Seil da grade. Ähm und das ist einfach, ne, die recht, also die Konsequenzen sind in den USA einfach echt sehr viel härter als als hierzulande beispielsweise. Ähm,
ist aber im Übrigen auch nicht neu, also auch auf dem Kongress hat ja schon mal Nick Mary von seinem Fall gesprochen, der ähm auch äh im Grunde in einer ähnlichen Situation war, so einen kleinen ISP betrieben hat, glaube ich oder ich weiß gar nicht, was es genau war und.
Ein so ein National Security Letter bekommen hat,
Das heißt, die Ansage, vermutlich es weiß bis jetzt niemand, was da drin stand, das erkunden Daten überreichen soll und ähm außerdem mit niemandem darüber sprechen auf einer sehr großartigen Talkfinde
gehalten dadrüber
wo er auch erzählt hat, dass er mit also auch mit seiner Freundin und seiner Familie und mit niemandem darüber sprechen durfte, unter anderem harter Strafen und sich dann juristisch dagegen gewehrt hat und diese Geschichte ist wirklich bemerkenswert, finde ich. Ähm,
aber eben auch, also auch da wird klar, es gibt von diesen NSL ähm ganz viele und fast niemand traut sich irgendwas darüber zu sagen und äh ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ob habe ich jetzt auch so ein Ding gekriegt oder was die genau, das wird ja auch nicht gesagt, aber diese also,
Finde ich, das ist so auf zweiter Ebene wirklich bemerkenswert dabei, die die ne Land of the free, dass das Land, was ähm nicht nur juristisch äh solche Maßnahmen ähm,
Nutzt und ähm dazu sicherlich berechtigt ist, was man jetzt davon hält, egal. Und dann aber die Leute, die davon betroffen sind,
unter unter anderem solcher Strafen dazu zwingt, nicht da nicht mal darüber reden zu können und zwar auch mit Anwälten nicht darüber reden zu dürfen. Das ähm,
Setzt den nochmal.
Nicht mal mit Anwälten.
Nein, nein, Nick mal, durfte auch eigentlich mit niemand auch mit einem Anwalt nicht dabei. Der durfte mit überhaupt niemandem darüber sprechen. Er hat's dann doch gemacht.
Aber dagegen klagen darf man dann trotzdem.
Eigentlich nicht. Der hat sozusagen erstmal das Recht, durchsetzen müssen, sich juristisch wehren zu können und das ging über Jahre, das ist eine ganz lange Geschichte.
Aber das ist ihm gelungen.
Das ist ihm dann gelungen. Er ist einer der ganz Wenigen. Ähm ich glaube, es gab, er hat in seinem Talk, glaube ich, erzählt, es gab irgendwie neun Fälle oder so, also es gab da noch irgendwelche Bibliotheksangestellten, die auch sowas hatten. Grund habe ich vergessen. Ähm.
Diese Gag-Orders betrafen übrigens auch ähm den Fall als die äh äh
diese Briefe gingen an Gmail, Twitter und so, weil sie die Daten von Rob äh Gongripe, check Apple Baum, Brigitte und ich glaube, Julian Assange haben wollten
und das ist ja auch ein Gerichtsverfahren. Wir haben da ähm einige wir haben da ja hier auch über den Verlauf berichtet. Wo Twitter erst einmal
kämpft hat, dass sie die Leute darüber informieren dürfen und damit erstmal ermöglicht haben, dass Rob und die anderen dagegen klagen konnten, was sie natürlich dann trotzdem verloren haben, ja?
Gab doch auch jetzt nach der ersten irgendwie nach dem ersten Lied von Snowden auch diese Meldung, dass Microsoft und Amazon irgendwie versuchen, richtig durchzusetzen, dass sie ja. Ähm.
Darüber berichten dürfen, was sie für Anfragen bekommen, ja.
Ja, das wird zumindest mal Zahlen nennen dürfen. Wenn noch nicht die einzelnen Fälle.
Schöne Demokratie.
Es ging schon vor einiger Zeit äh und zwar im Anfang Juni über die Liberation Tech Mailing Liste eine kurze Mail von John Gilmore. Äh der mal die Frage beantwortete, warum denn die ähm.
Tief die Direktoren von solchen Techfirmen nicht äh verraten, dass bei ihnen abgehört wird. Und er hat dann den Fall beschrieben der Firma Q West ähm und das wurde also diese Firma wurde
äh wurde kontaktiert von NSA oder was auch immer und sagten, wir würden gerne hier äh eure äh Kunden,
abhören und der CEO hat dann irgendwie mit seinem mit seinen Anwälten gesprochen und hat dann sich geweigert das zu tun.
Äh die das Resultat war, dass äh mehrere Milliarden Dollar äh Verträge äh mit dieser Firma ähm.
Gecancelt wurden. Das heißt, sie hatten einen massiven Verlust und ähm er wurde dann wegen Insidergeschäften äh verfolgt und sitzt noch heute im Knast äh mit einem sechs Jahre,
aufgrund eines sechs Jahre Verurteilung wegen halt Insidertraining oder sowas, ja? Das heißt.
Also ich verlinke das nochmal genau, wie wie John den Fall da erklärt. Ähm,
Aber es ist also auf vielen, vielen Ebenen wohl nicht geraten, sich mit diesen äh Agencys äh anzulegen, ja. Ähm.
Und die nächste Frage, die sich ja jetzt gerade sicherlich ganz viele Leute stellen, ähm also gestern Abend Lavabit über Nachtilentmail und wie geht das jetzt weiter?
Hat aber freiwillig zu.
Ja ja also aber ich also denken wir mal, also wissen wir ja auch immer, also ich du musst, glaube ich, bei allem immer die Frage stellen, was wissen wir jetzt hier gerade nicht von dem, was was hier gerade bekannt wird
und ähm was, was, was was passiert
Na, jetzt essen jetzt die, was für eine Welle geht denn da gerade los und er so, ich habe irgendwann heute Morgen, als ich das gesehen habe, muss ich jetzt
eine Signatur unter meine E-Mails schreiben, die bei Rise Up gehostet sind, was ein Provider ist, wo ich denke, die werden mir mitteilen, wenn sie was haben, ähm aber auch in den USA und wo ich jetzt drunterschreibe, falls es Rise Up nicht mehr gibt, könnt ihr mich da und da erreichen.
Ähm.
Würde ich jetzt mal langsam Backup machen von den Mails, die da gehostet sind, weil äh also man, die werden auf jeden Fall jetzt auch äh,
Es ist echt hart.
Jetzt äh rasen wir noch schnell durch die durch die Kurzmeldung und dann muss ich langsam los. Es wird eng. Ähm,
Und zwar ist die der zweite Entwurf der Verordnung des Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums zur Netzneutralität äh jetzt aufgetaucht. Ich habe ihn ausgedruckt vor mir liegen. Kurz gefasst ist es äh ist dort
ist das Ding ziemlich genau das, was es in den USA gibt,
äh dass man sagt, ja, wir wollen Netzneutralität, klar, es muss ein diskriminierungsfreies Internet geben ähm und Managed Services geht das natürlich auch geben.
Aber nicht für alle, so.
Da steht also
Ähm ist relativ klar äh Netznetralität definiert und so kann man gar nichts drüber sagen und dann heißt es irgendwie ein Paragraph zwei Absatz drei äh eine inhaltsneutrale an technischen Erfordernissen orientierte Transportklassifizierung in Klammern
Qualitätsdienstklassen,
keine willkürliche Verschlechterung von Diensten, solange dem Endnutzer Wahlmöglichkeiten erhalten bleiben. Eine Differenzierung von Entgelten nach Qualitätsdienstklassen ist
keine ungerechtfertigte Behinderung oder Verlangsamung des Datenverkehrs. Das heißt, man schreibt hin Netzwerk großes Ding, ähm,
und ist aber nicht verletzt, wenn man sie verletzt. So
die Kurzfassung, ja, also ähm und das erinnert mich sehr stark, ich habe da jetzt die die äh direkte Übersetzung mit der deutschen Regulation noch äh mit der US-Regulation nicht gemacht, aber einen Satz erinnert mich daran, die willkürliche Verschlechterung von Diensten oder die ungerechtfertigte Behinderung oder Verlangsamung des Datenverkehrs
in den Telekommunikationsnetzen ist nicht zulässig
ungerechtfertigt, ja? Also das ist genau in der, in der USA äh in den USA Gesetz, in Netzneutalität, auch das dringen. Ähm was heißt unbegründet oder oder ungerechtfertigt? Also,
Es steht genau das auch drin. Das heißt, wenn ich's.
Gemacht werden, es sei denn, es gibt einen Grund.
Es gibt einen Grund, ja. Darf's nicht gemacht werden, es sei es gibt einen Grund und wenn es einen Grund gibt oder wenn du unterschiedliche Qualitätskassen anbietest, darfst du es sowieso.
Warum ist meine Leitung so langsam, ne, aus Gründen? Ach so, na dann. Hm. Ja.
Aus Gründen ist ist da das äh entscheidende Meme. Ja, also ähm ich würde das gerne in der äh in der nächsten Folge nochmal genauer behandeln, aber das ist also auch äh,
Also es ist, es ist genau das das USA-Dingen, dass man sagt, ja, wir schreiben ein Netz.
Aber das würde ja nun vor der Wahl jetzt eh nicht mehr ausgehandelt werden.
Eine Entscheidung ist in dieser Legislaturperiode nicht mehr vorgesehen, aber da muss man also ein Auge draufhalten.
Manning, das ist die zweite Kurzmeldung, wobei es mir jetzt auch schmerzt, das als Kurzmeldung dazu machen. Äh verurteilt ist er ja,
Ähm ich glaube, das das war dann auch genau an dem Tag, als Julian Assange dann da sein. Äh und zwar ist er in allen so und so über zwanzig Anklagepunkten schuldig gesprochen worden, außer in dem.
Ading ist also Hochverrat und äh also Treasen und dieses wurde ihm also, davon wurde er,
freigesprochen und das wäre die Todesstrafe gewesen. Oder da hätte die vor Todesstrafe drauf ausgesprochen werden können und er ist jetzt in der glücklichen Position.
Knast kriegen könnte.
Nur hundertsechsunddreißig Jahre Knast, wobei sie jetzt sogar schon äh mit sich verhandeln lassen. Ob man das nicht vielleicht runter äh das das Höchststrafmaß runterverhandelt auf neunzig Jahre
ja? Wobei das ist dann immer noch die Höchststrafe. Es könnte sein, dass die dass die das Gericht ähm eben nicht die Höchststrafe verhängt, aus welchem.
Übrigens ganz interessant im Spiegel von dieser Woche ohne also ich weiß, dass dass sich das nicht gehört, den Spiel jetzt hier nochmal anzubringen, aber ähm berichtet Holger Stark von der Urteils also ich weiß nicht, ist das jetzt die Urteilsverkündung gewesen? Ja, ne?
Ähm ähm weil das genau das Strafmaß kommt dann später ähm äh Urteilsverkündung und ähm,
Heuer Stark ist ja jetzt der neue US-Korrespondent des Spiegel und hat sozusagen genau sein Thema da jetzt auch gefunden. Und ähm den Bericht finde ich ziemlich gut und da kommt das Detail drin vor, dass in in dieser Verhandlung auch nochmal irgendwer
eingeworfen hat, dass dass es eigentlich, dass er noch wegen Mord verurteilt werden müsste, weil ja da von irgendeinem,
Afghanen bekannt sei, dass er jetzt deswegen äh gestorben sei,
und und nur sozusagen durch so ein akuten Einwurf nochmal das Anwalts, dafür gäbe es aber keine Belege,
nochmal sozusagen von der Richterin anerkannt wurde, dass das jetzt ein reines Gerücht war. Ich kann das nicht mehr so richtig gut wiedergeben, aber also lohnt sich zu lesen, diese diese Detailbeschreibung, was da in dem Saal passiert ist.
Das ist echt geil.
Also das finde ich auch einen interessanten Punkt, weil das ist ähm bisher ja immer in dieser ganzen Geschichte ähm aus den USA und auch von der Regierung immer wieder
behauptet worden, dass das deswegen ähm überhaupt kein Whistle Blowing und so ein Problem gewesen sei, weil so viele Unschuldige leben davon betroffen sind, dass das alles geliebt worden ist und das ist mir selber auch passiert, als ich bei dieser
netzpolitischen Reise letztes Jahr unter anderem auch in Washington mit ich weiß gar nicht mehr
was, was die Funktion war irgendwie Digitalfuzzi in der der Obama-Administration mich unterhalten habe und auch irgendwie nochmal den angesprochen habe und auch der hat mir dann gesagt, ja
wisselblauer sind natürlich super, aber Brad De Manning ist ja keiner und irgendwie die ganzen Leute, die gestorben sind wegen der Sachen, die da geliebt hat. Also das es wird immer wieder ja auch
portiert und das haben sie bis zum Schluss, bis in der Urteilsverkündung versucht und da ist aber festgehalten worden und ist jetzt damit auch gerichtsfest, dass es solche Fälle nicht gibt.
Ja, wobei wahrscheinlich die Leute, wo er dann ganz klar bewiesen hat, dass sie unschuldige Leute erschossen haben, uns da auch noch live on Tape sozusagen gezeigt wurde, bestimmt noch keinerlei nennenswerte Konsequenzen haben.
Bin ich relativ sicher.
Ja. So, na dann, wir wollten Kurznachrichten machen. Machen wir Kurznachrichten, womit geht's weiter?
Wir hatten's schon erwähnt, im im Juni hatte das, wurde das Gesetz äh vom Bundestag abgenickt und ist jetzt auch mit dem ersten August in Kraft getreten. Das war das Gesetz, wo ich als äh Sachverständiger nochmal im,
Innenausschuss gesagt hatte, dass ich davor warnen möchte,
Und ich denke, dass ähm das jetzt vor dem Hintergrund dieser ganzen Abhörgeschichten eben nochmal eine ganz andere Bewandtnis hat, ne? Weil ja klar war, dass so designed ist, dass es ähm.
E-Mail, Sicherheits, Best Prasses umsetzt
und aber keine Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung hat, sodass ein Zugriff äh der Dienste erhalten bleibt. Und ähm das war auch der einzige Grund, da auf eine Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung zu verzichten und vor dem Hintergrund dieser ganzen Abhörthematiken,
ist es natürlich
Ja, wie gesagt, noch mal sehr interessant, wenn da jetzt der Bitcom sagt, wir wollen IT-Sicherheits-TÜV haben, was ja sowieso schon mal Unsinn ist. Und wir gerade hier in Deutschland genau solche äh neue, sichere Infrastruktur bauen, die eben
dass Angreifermodell ausländischer Staat hat und das äh Abhörmodell äh,
auch ganz klar mit eingebaut hat, ja? Also so wird IT-Sicherheit jetzt ähm verstanden oder wurde sie auch schon immer verstanden?
Tja, also wenn da jetzt wirklich ein neuer Kuchen entsteht, da will die Amerikaner Markt freigeben. Deutschland scheint die nicht unbedingt zu besetzen.
Nee, genau, also Deutschland will den jetzt besetzen mit, ja, das ist jetzt hier sicher, garantiert kein Zugriff durch Amerikaner, würde ich glauben, ja. Ist gut, haben sie, ja, haben sie gut gemacht, das ist nun nicht meine Sorge, ja.
Also es äh es es gibt einen sicheren Dienst, nur das Angreifermodell, vor dem dieser Dienst schützt äh ist eben äh.
Und dann noch äh wollen wir am Ende noch eine positive Meldung haben. Ja, wir wollen ja immer noch eine positive Meldung haben, dass Crowdfunding der äh C3S hart nach neunzehn Tagen,
seine fünfzigtausend Euro erreicht, die es zum Fortbestehen braucht, strebt natürlich jetzt die einhunderttausend an. Ähm,
da können wir gratulieren.
Darf ich in dem Kontext gerne noch ein Crowdfunding bekannt,
cool. Ähm unter anderem Smary McCarthy, also einer der Direktoren der ähm Crowdfundet gerade für einen neuen verschlüsselten Mailservice, Mailpeil genannt. Ähm und ich also wenn der da mit drin ist, bin ich ganz zuversichtlich, dass das eine gute Sache ist und äh momentan nötiger denn je, also
schaut euch das doch auch mal an und gebt was dazu.
Gut. Das war jetzt eine überlange Sendung. Aber ich glaube, das war mal ganz angemessen. Osten hatten wir ja eine ausgelassen. Diesmal gehen wir dann, glaube ich, mal wieder auf etwas äh überschaubare äh Sendezeiträume, oder?
Mhm. Versuchen wir, ja, je nachdem wie viel passiert.
Aber ich äh hoffe, dass es trotzdem alles in eurem Sinne war. Anne, vielen Dank für deinen Besuch hier.
Gerne. Danke für die Einladung.
Muss noch was zu sagen? Sonst nicht. Gut, dann bis bald. Tschüss.